there it is probably had a little glitch
there everybody got the uh
the shirt even though i will say the
loot in there this weekend apparently is
worth going for because it's apparently
all good
hand cannons at five uh flawless
is messenger adept oh and then i think
the sword is at seven and the arms are
at three
so arm's at three hand cannon five five
arms of three hand cannon five flawless
is messenger
so you can go for your adept messenger
and then sword i think is seven
he literally got all three what did you
say this were zero kills
for zero kills yeah you get actually
what you get
flawless you get salt and tears salt and
tears at zero
okay okay yeah i hope you got plenty of
space in your inventory for those you're
going to be getting a lot yeah
everybody's gonna pull it away with
seven months thank you very much nine
months i'm sorry
thank you well that's the homie right
there salute pull it away
in fact what's going on daniel
dakota
nathan is like this guy is on my pvp
level oh believe me mine too
if i took me a couple random people into
trials i'd be like how was your trials
weekend
i got like three tokens how long were
you in there about 10 hours
feels bad
all around in destiny 1 so yeah i went
like 14 times
i think i've been once ever cobb i'm
gonna need that artwork that you got
with the osiris with the the carry bag
that's the channel that's that's all
about that
when i saw that bubble i got this open
i thought that was pretty funny yeah
that was [ __ ] my eyes in the back of
the bed
the garyvee osiris joy i love it
hey he's got all supers he's got to be a
bit op vagabondo gives that well i mean
if you're very much
if you're a vex uh you know minotaur you
can just push him on the ground
you know or if you're saint 14 just
punch the crap that scene was so
terrible and then here comes crow you
know oh
like he's supposed to be this badass
we're talking about it
yeah and then shout out to all you guys
shout out to all you guys in chat thank
you guys for joining us tonight
the art that will be on the background
i'll probably flip it about halfway too
we've got two images
both by our guest here tonight so we got
a cade just
awesome looks kind of like splatter ink
art and we've also got the
mask of backrest if i read that
correctly so both pretty legit looking
those kind of fit the best for the
background so
if you're listening to this on video
cool
if you guys are listening to this on
audio shout out to all of you guys on
audio by the way
i know we're recording and this won't
even make it here no i was gonna say had
our first
episode break a thousand listen so thank
you guys very much
shout out to your fire team chat
appearance my fire team chat appearance
and just all of you out there
the combined forces of ollie guys thank
you guys very much that's just the
pre-show love we haven't even started
yet so
that being said let's do it dally
wait did we collapse no we didn't
yeah i'm off my game sorry oh yeah that
pre-workout i'll take it in that's what
it is
the pre-workout's already been used up
it's all pure work that's all on my
biceps right now yep
let's go cop let's get the uh claps
going all right
you want to do a clap real quick because
he has to sink
yeah or are you going to count it down
or would you stall oh no you just give
you
away yeah just like two or three claps
oh we got ninja claps i heard nothing
so here's the idea take your claps move
them out here
oh and go
let's see nope he got the same
so here's the idea talk softly into the
mic so be like all right hello
hey mike can you hear my collabs
seriously nothing okay
then do
i just need a sharp peek that's all i'm
going for for matching you know about
this
peak
all right testing one two three
that works for you all right but now i
never used to i used to have the same
problem cobb would have
no i don't know yetis maybe yeah it's
yeti it's yeti there's some type of
internal noise canceling thing that it
does and it's just
annoying can't figure it out
anyway all right uh stream keeps
repeating itself place for a few seconds
if you guys have stream issues make sure
you guys refresh everything i literally
can't even load my twitch
like i can't even load it it's just
spinny bars
i'm seeing a clean upload right now so
zero dropped frames so just if it does
just like close the browser
probably on my side well it's like close
the browser and open it back up or a
brand new window or something usually
helps a little bit
okay i think it looks like it's popping
up pretty quickly now
i mean chrome eats like you know 20 gigs
of memory so what are you going to do
i've got 32 gigs of memory and i've
usually got just a little space thanks
to chrome
well some people are born with just a
little space just
just a little extra yeah i've got it
yeah i was like i got just a little
extra i'm working on but that's
different
no i've been a kickboxing instructor for
like four years i should be shredded and
i just love food so
i don't have an excuse i should be i
should be like walking around with like
six packs
not yet listen
[Music]
ready to rock yep all right everybody
thanks for joining early let's get ready
five seconds silence on the set
oh oh turn this down yeah
and we are alive
[Laughter]
the last word with lord cognito
anybody's friday evening campfire what's
going
on e how are we doing pretty good just
got uh kind of squeezed in everything at
the end of the day i got a workout in
with my wife
got some food in got a protein shake
showered all within like 30 minutes so
got a chance to jump on here
and we are joined uh with an awesome
guest
so let's bring him into the campfire and
thank you guys for joining us tonight
around the campfire so here we go
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the campfire of the last word
tonight
we are joined by a guest of many talents
so let's shed some light on this
fine gentleman's history to start he is
one of the og
oggiest gamers of all time planting his
gaming roost back in
pong and pitfall during the atari 2600
days
gaming has continued to be a passion
with everything from final fantasy 7 on
ps1
many many years of madden in nba and
fighting games of all types
blood no blood it's all in there but he
is far more than a gamer his true
talents lie in the amazing creations he
puts on paper
canvas and screen it started back in
grade school where being an artist was
more fun than just about anything else
he may not have had a history with
bungie but when he found the beta
we all know too well fate had its hooks
in
after that things really took off when
the forces of artist gamer destiny
combined to make the man we have with us
tonight
we are going to need to hold back the
lady ladies because this is about to
read like an online dating profile this
man is an amazing father
proud home chef hip-hop producer b-ball
player so you know he's got to be tall
never xbox owner cashed in as all his
rng chips in the vault of glass
will cook you dinner and then take you
out for a walk into the stars
while explaining the constellations and
drawing your experience to be remembered
forever
let's have a big welcome for amazing
guest of episode 140 the one
the only kobe 1 art welcome sir how are
you doing
i am doing well thank you so much let me
just
gotta give it up guys the greatest intro
ever
podcast i am i'm i'm working on having
me i'm super excited and i appreciate it
absolutely
that was that was amazing and very
truthful everything was like
amazing he does his research i've been
i've been taught
i've been taught by the best you're the
hot ones of destiny
i know exactly what you're talking about
yeah i was like man you do your research
he's like yeah we definitely do
we we just try to dig a little we try
and dig a little deeper you know make
the episode special for our guests this
is why you wanted my social
media he said what about we
yeah yeah we got to make sure your
credit score is good enough to be on the
podcast you know gotta hit that
market yeah dude how are you doing man
thank you for joining us tonight what
are you been up to
feeling good tgif by the way indeed
uh just work art family
what's those three things and games
games those four things
but uh yeah it's just busy busy yeah
so yeah just living life in these crazy
times right now so
we're canceling you know cartoon
characters and
life's a little weird but we'll try and
get through basically each day at a time
exactly man one thing let's jump right
into it because one thing i like as a
fellow og
you know saying for my uh you know i
would definitely respect your history
and uh with gaming man like you you drop
some balls on me man
2600 colecovis people don't know what
these
mean talk to them talk to the people
yeah um so when i was little little
uh my dad had pong so okay it's kind of
my dad's fault i was into games
um didn't do a whole lot of pong but i
remember it um
and then atari we got an atari and it
was
like pitfall combat all those early ones
oh man i was hooked and from there it
just snowballed like
literally every system over the years i
know my mom hated me growing up but
it was fair everything 3do neogeo like
with the giant controllers they were
like
the games were like vcr cartridges
no they were like a hundred dollars a
piece exactly yeah the neo geo era
lasted about a year
yeah yeah yeah wanted to ask your quick
thoughts on these 60
game prices do you approve of the 70
increase
um i mean
you know for all the entertainment and
the value in the hours and hours you get
a plan
i don't mind paying it you know that's
why i don't mind with destiny pitching
into eververse
you know every few months or something
for some you know emotions kind of like
your unofficial subscription price
basically
you know they don't easily charge you
know guardians something a month to
you know sustain it and they don't you
know they just nickel and dime us on
every verse
[Laughter]
oh you just wait for that transmog it's
coming
so yeah yeah yeah man
tremendous history i guess i love love
again very similar to my gamer
yeah like very similar dad got me in and
it was one of those things
every console generation pretty much you
know
had it going on since then man i think
uh high school years it was
very very into fighting games that was
the uh you know street fighter
mortal kombat to tekken to the put your
quarter up
i'm next lining them up on my little
window
they don't know about that walking up to
the arcade bunch of kids packed around a
big
street fighter and you come up put your
quarter and look around like yeah
i tell people all the time it's such a
different era because one
from a competition standpoint you know
what i'm saying and literally facing
your opponent it's before the
online era you get everybody's circles
going
like literally elbow to elbow and the
last thing people don't realize is that
like
the arcade at the time like that was our
next gen whenever the new technology
would come out
you know go to the arcade because that
was the few that was better that was
what was your house console-wise so you
heard when that new game came out
oh did you hear yeah everybody was there
you just remember a game like i remember
one that seemed to like set itself apart
and it's like i don't even know how old
it is now but like
it was always one of those that seemed
to even be a more modern arcade like
hydro thunder
like that one when i saw it was like
that looks pretty like it
again that's kind of thing now you have
like series x pcs like
arcades are like never gonna do that
anymore unless it's more than
it's more like the vr experience stuff
like that the kind of big connections
but
that was still one of those that i
remember there was like a sniper one but
it was
it was that was the thing it's like the
big tz's the technology was just
bigger they could throw more in the damn
arcade thing so no i even remember
it was like a 55 inch and we were like
oh the big ones and now you know we got
like 80 inches on our wall
you're right you're right and that's a
good point because a lot of the rk2 even
if it was the same game sometimes you
had different variants you had like
racing games that sometimes you you sat
in you know what i'm saying
and stuff like that then other times you
have ones that were just a stand-up
upright
and it just had the basic wheel or
whatever it was you remember the ferrari
game with like the actual clutch and
stick that had the the
gates oh yeah oh see the there's
one there's the golden gate bridge or
something uh what was it what's that
cruising cruising i mean
it was cruising usa or cruising or
cruising there's a world or cruising usa
there was also like san francisco russia
i remember too
that might be the one i'm confusing with
it they're both good but yeah there's
what you know about that how about how
about what is it off-road with like the
wheels that you could just freely spin
like the four wheels that are stuck on
the isometric yep
you have four people yeah the isometric
little like rally trucks that ones
that's the older one for sure
what's in the uh golden axe vein oh
that's my jam right there
yeah that was fun era man love that era
what you got for me because
i can talk arcade with him all day oh no
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna drop this
bomb so we can get it out of the way
get it you have never
owned an x-box no
no never yep so
obviously you literally go through
because we asked you and you're like
i've had literally every system
except the biggest caveat i've heard for
gaming
zero xboxes ever yeah
this coming from my co-host who
literally hosts an
xbox pod mostly xbox leaning
it's a pretty green podcast pretty great
um but seriously like how did you go
from like
no halo history as well skipping that
one to go what made you find the beta
for destiny because that
most a lot of our guests are like halo
to destiny we
have had a few recently that haven't but
for you that's an even bigger one
yeah yeah it's um
when ps1 came out i believe it was 94
ish 95 and we have to check dates
um i got it for my birthday super pumped
and you know there was no
xbox back then that was the premiere
everything
actual so you know i had my playstation
i think xbox did come out a little later
but you know already have mine okay well
ps2 comes out i'm like well
i got the playstation i should just get
and it's just been this family history
of playstations over time so it's not
like this
oh i hate xbox but i have friends that
are hardcore gamers too and they
literally will buy both
systems and just to play one game on
xbox but there's
there's just never been that game for me
that's a system seller you know and it's
not out of the question but they just
fable was close maybe
there's a new one coming out um but yeah
no hate on xbox um
the whole halo days uh i had friends
yeah i was gonna ask you how did you
escape the halo that's why i had friends
that were playing halo
and uh in that time in my life um
i think i is when i first got into music
production and uh
i like i kind of drifted out of games
for a while so that was kind of an error
but i did have friends that played it
and um
one buddy had a pamper party because he
was having a kid and
he had a halo tournament like the old
school land party two times all set up
in the river room cables and wires
everywhere
and uh and i murked them never played it
and i
tore up all these halo players and they
were like no you played this before
but that was my first experience with
halo and um
and i just played it at friends houses i
never was like i have to have this you
know i've never
been into that franchise i respect it i
think it's a cool franchise
and then fast forward to when
ps4 was about to come out yeah
and all my friends who did have halo
backgrounds are like dude this game
bungie's making
and i knew who bungie was of course so i
was like okay
never played halo never played a bungee
game i'm pretty pumped
um and uh i didn't pull the trigger on
the super duper collector's ghost
edition
which i got later thank goodness okay um
but uh i i was still kind of like well
we'll see
and little did i know this game would
like take hold of my life
you know meet so many new people hooks
excuse me yeah
changes um you know i led a clan for
many years and we hop between you know
kill zones and call of duty's and all
those
and no game ever like kept our attention
for more than two or three months we
were hopping from
first person to the next not destiny
destiny was like you know we'll play
this other one for a little bit but
we'll come back right now
and to this day it's you know they still
managed to put that carrot out in front
of you
absolutely man not completely
understandable because um
it makes sense everything you said based
on your gaming history
and look people forget playstation one
was so
dominant when it came out with such a
revolution you know what i'm saying
in graphically 3d i remember since
you're fighting games
i throw a couple at you i remember i was
a battle arena to shinden
yes that so it was doing a lot of things
revolutionary and then of course
leading it now you into ps2 you're gonna
say which was a
juggernaut and you're a man you remember
how
madden looked on ps4 for the first time
yes mind blowing so i remember looking
madden i ever
uh got was on 3do like the first really
good looking mountain
yes the big dude like the actual they
didn't look like other cartoon dudes you
know
that's pretty tempting i'm glad you
better treat it people sleep with three
years video was about
you don't remember that yeah yeah man
remember where is the warrior
naughty dog's first
but it was a good effort naughty dog
shaky jake
remember the characters oh my god i'm a
prison dude
like some whack ass literally like
if you ever see this game it was like
literally the the team just grabbed
their friends
and digitized their friends and put on
suits like you could tell they didn't
have much back it's
early naughty dog but it was it had a
charm to it it had a jaw
it was fun it was like a logo had a dog
on it i think
then there was a ripoff rating like
lightning boy or something
bad fighters though clay fighter oh
back in the day was that n64 might have
been there was like clay fighter 33 and
a third or something weird-ass
super nintendo super nintendo and n64 i
think it was both
yes okay yeah yeah that was also
questionable
yeah man like i said though i do
understand based on what you would say
get uh
upset you have something sound like
you're looking so uh
the anniversary of his death couple days
oh he just popped in my head
shout out recipe rest in peace the
biggie small
you know what i'm saying but that's what
i got on the history that was that was
dope now you want to get
into that destiny because he's got some
uh he's got some stupid stuff there
yeah i was gonna say i don't know if i
can steal this one from you for his
career highlight
but oh this is you you gotta you gotta
ask like
what what is this because this this
speaks 100 percent to you
mm-hmm i mean well let's get it i
when i i was reading things about you
and then when you
you actually said it first of all we you
know have everyone knows how i feel
about fault
everybody knows that you know say it's
documented i got my taken kick shirt all
in respect but everybody knows how i
feel about
faulting there's a vault of glass shirt
he's gonna buy like six of them next
season
you know next you know next month
they're gonna do it most like you know
saying cause
they're gonna bring it back but the
thing that i never
knew which you accomplished
which is some uh one of the most major
drops at the end
of a i've never i didn't
how salty was your people oh my god
for you i didn't believe it they didn't
believe it i had to send that screen cap
to everybody after the thing they didn't
believe what happened oh i'm sure
let's get it yeah uh yeah um vault of
glass
uh many memories in there probably the
one raid besides king's fall that i did
the most
uh and i don't know it just had that
journey to the center of the earth
like to this day those activities and
destiny are what i love the best the
hawkmoon
the whisper like those quests where it's
just
the massive scale and you're just going
deeper
and deeper and deeper into tunnels and i
just i like that i
i don't know but and again it was the
first ever raid
and i remember the whole time thinking
like how did people figure this out
the whole time like how did people map
this out this is nuts
um but yeah uh i got uh
we beat atheon um and this was i had
already gotten the vex and gallahorn i
had already had
you know that before so this was just
kind of a double
add but um it was uh it was
what two heads and lord helmets the ship
gallerhorn
and uh vex smith the class all in one
you say that so
subtly two helmets which is usually what
kept people like at forever 29 or at
least some people
be was one of them vex mythoclast
and galahorn in the same drop and the
ship
like that is literally everything he can
drop and you got was there like a
challenge or hard or something you did
to get like an extra
camera you just got it all you just got
like i mean it was obviously
hard mode um because i think vex only
dropped on that one but
right no way i think at that point when
i got that drop
we were just steamrolling through there
you know like we had already kind of
so it wasn't like it was the most
exciting drop i've ever had but it it um
it wasn't a needed drop when it happened
but it was still pretty spectacular so
that's
awesome when anyone asks me best moment
i always go to that because that is just
that's
crazy pretty hard to beat that's yeah i
had the most insane rng in destiny 1
like my clan
i had all the exotics like before anyone
had half of them
like for some reason i just like in pvp
i'd be the last
dude and boom icebreaker okay
you that dude we got one of my clan as
an addict yeah oh yeah but
now that did not carry over to destiny
too just
stop blessing you're pretty good in
outriders though ah there you go
we'll have to talk about that in the end
because that's yeah all right all right
hello salute okay no
like that one's just kind of amazing
though just to see but it is cool i was
like actually kind of curious how you
say
i'm definitely the odd man out in the
classes this week
because we got kind of an og warlock but
now hunter
so which one has more hours than destiny
2. i'm curious
um gosh i would honestly probably say my
hunter um
okay what happens is
i would play all three and try to keep
up light level of course you know i
gotta do
this this this this week on this guy oh
let me hop tunes and
and that became um they came out with
way more things to do
and then um the time became less too
of my available time to play so those
two
together you know um
i just wasn't able to get on like i used
to get on but um
what is your sub class of choice now for
both warlock and hunter depending on
your time to play what's your subclass
of choice
um destiny 1 it was all nova bombs i
have a
i have a uh i was a master at the cross
map
i could i could aim up and just cross
map people i have a collection video on
youtube i have to send it to you guys
that's dope but um nova bomb but i say
in destiny 2 i probably run
tickle fingers more on the the um
it's a rare one i just i used to run
blade a lot but it was just so wimpy to
me i would hit people direct
and just nothing i'm like what does this
thing even feel powerful yeah it didn't
feel bad yeah it was just pretty weak so
powerful now
now it's powerful with the uh what you
call it with the helmet the bug out at
home oh god that thing's brutal
but i agree dawn blade looked cool look
cooler than it was
effectively at first i agree but
yeah no what i was going to say is that
the time became less so
uh i got i was on my hunter
which at the time i can't remember which
dlc or whatnot it was on but i was like
i was maxed with him out of all my three
so i was like you know what i'll just
stay on my hunter
for this and just keep it rolling into
the new stuff well there was so much
stuff
i just never i never caught up with the
hunter and literally went through a
whole season i don't even think i
touched my warlock or my
my titan the fabric and um and that's
just kind of how
how it happens and then like you know i
still jump on them to do activities but
always like
you know pvp let me get on my hunter you
know i'm just
i've gotten so used to the dive reload
and you know
it's torture when i jump on my warlock
and get in pvp
oh yeah you betrayed the floof i know
i know i i'm still a really good floofer
though
ah see he's got you there a lot of
people don't know the key to a beautiful
warlock
junk they all think it you know a lot of
people jump and then hit flight
and they lose so much that's me you
gotta double tap x or whatever like
as fast as you can boom and it launches
you like a cannon but a lot of people
don't know that
so that's the tip from your uncle cup i
i appreciate god because
that is definitely begging my head and
then him not mantling and then
falling to a death yeah now i like i
like the fluffle and descent
controlling where i'm going
you know what i'm saying kind of thing
but now man that tremendous man i i love
hearing those stories i'm with you
on the whole you know that's what
happened to me it would transform me
into a one
character kind of guy because it was
just like as destiny grew the activity
just became
so more immense and my time started to
go down so it's just like all right
i got to make a decision you know and i
was like okay i'm locking
in to this because the multi-character
life is very tough and i
respect all that can do it but it's
definitely harder for me but what i was
going to ask you on
on the art side if i may it's on one
thing that
you know we share that also is cool is
that obviously
from that golden era you know what i'm
saying that that hip hop that you know
what i'm saying that 90s
i respect it so cool thing that i
thought as far as your origin on the art
side
was the graffiti aspect you know i said
like i thought that was cool so
like did that help transition you as far
before you got into art because
people don't realize like during that a
era 80s 90s hip-hop
graffiti tagging that was the thing that
was a true expression
of so that's the four elements of
hip-hop you already know
so i i did all the four elements
breakdancing i just
um not he wasn't playing he wasn't
not me um well uh
you know i've always been doing art
since i could hold a pencil like
my earliest memories but as far as the
graffiti aspect um that is where the
name
cobb one came in um but back in growing
up in fayetteville north carolina you
know
graf just wasn't like a thing there you
know and and i loved it i was all into
hip-hop i loved graffiti i used to
collect the magazines i used to draw it
and um it wasn't until i moved to
albuquerque in 2003
and my newfound family member cousin was
all into doing
big graffiti murals and paintings so he
started taking me out to all the spots
and i would practice and
i eventually got like a a big four foot
by eight foot
um uh plywood to put my garage
okay and just practice i would do a
whole piece and i'll just paint over it
and do a whole piece
paint over it and i kept doing that so i
felt like all right i think i'm ready to
go back out to the yards
because what happened my cousin took me
out to the spots
first time ever never and i i was so
embarrassed like with my stuff i was
just like oh it was bad i wanted to like
diss myself and paint over it
so that's when i was like you know tail
between my legs i was like i gotta
regroup so
started practicing in my garage and and
you know there's techniques that i
didn't know
at the time but once those techniques
hit and i learned them it was just like
you know like cutting like a point for
example i always thought people were
there
they're little spray paints doing a
point like wow that says how they do
that sharp point like that
they're just spraying two lines that may
crisscross and then you take the
background color and you
color over that yeah it's you just use
layers
yeah that's pretty cool it was the first
layers of photoshop right there
but yeah that's kind of how i got into
actually doing um
uh the graffiti spray paint aerosol
murals and stuff um i started that
in like oh four i would say and
and i had been painting like six months
in a local
graffiti contest came up from this like
head shop here in town
okay and i went out there it was a giant
parking lot and it was all four by eight
boards set up there was like 34 riders
out there
and um there was a half of them were
considered like
up and comers and the other half were
like veterans right well i ended up
getting first
out you're paying like six months but
yeah that that was pretty cool
that was pretty cool a lot of uh a lot
of the
the guys have been painting for a long
time that were out there so some of my
my mutual graffiti friends are like
you probably shouldn't tell anyone that
you only been painting like six months
i'm just a natural natural i got that
mozart like talent just given
i do pick up on things pretty quick my
whole life i've always just kind of been
adaptable you know but um but yeah so
that got me
i was into it i was going every weekend
to the yards painting new pieces
um if you google cobb one graffiti
you'll probably see some old stuff of
mine out there
um but um yeah so uh
you know i did that for a good little
few years i haven't painted probably
about a year or so i did a
little cade piece uh that's on my
instagram i think
uh just a quickie last year but i don't
get out there much
but that is where the name cobwin came
from it's a little
great history back hey i got more food
so
i wanted to ask you like i don't have a
whole lot of
create i don't have a whole lot of
creative bones in my body especially
when it comes to art like
you know making thumbnails is like
minimal stuff and copy and paste in here
and stuff and cropping but like
there like are a few pieces that i feel
like i've done okay has been like if
i've done like little baby pencil
sketches and stuff like that of like
there's a couple trees that i'm happy
with and a couple of things and it's
mostly pants
little trees yeah bob ross of destiny
over here so sure
oh yeah he definitely that's what my my
cobb mob calls me cobb ross
comrade yeah you're very
calm too you're like pretty chill and
everything i kind of see you in so it
makes sense
but it was like there was
one art class that there was like one
point where it's like okay do a tree and
i'm like okay so like and i'm gonna work
in like decent sized piece and it's like
pencil
as soon as i touch the thing with color
i feel like i ruin it
now i have like and and it's like and it
just kind of goes downhill and i'm not
happy with it anymore and like the only
couple time and again i don't do this
often it's only been a few times that i
can remember
but i was like have there any big any
big transitions for you whether it's
been like
you know certain line techniques that
you learn is there any big hurdle with
that first you're like this is awful i
don't know if and then
have there any big like kind of been
epiphany or techniques that you've
learned that kind of like transformed
you to
another level like any major styles
pieces
like editions or something that's a good
question
um i would say uh challenging things
digital when i first started digital it
was just and still
i'm literally still learning and making
things up as i go um i try to pick up
things from you know my buddies that are
really phenomenal at it
um but yeah i would just say like
techniques and digital just kind of
figuring things out you know getting in
there as far as like traditional
um i can't really think of any kind of
techniques or anything
um i have a graphic design background
that's what i went to college for
and um so early
my early days of doing like commissions
and art was a lot of logos it was a lot
of design work a lot of you know
typography
and i've since kind of gravitated out of
that um
realm i'll still do things here and
there design wise but um
you know now it's more just you know
actual art pieces and stuff but
i would say uh yeah just digital um
learning techniques and that you know
i'm still learning
um it's really tough the first time i
got on digital i was like
i felt it just feels like you're running
in mud like you don't
just can't get what like you can see in
your head this really cool piece
but you know to get it on the the
digital canvas
per se but um yeah i would say that okay
that's kind of a big one but yeah no
that's a big one that's a big one man
yeah man then obviously transition i
love a lot of the style of other pieces
that
that i've seen from you that are really
cool you know what i'm saying and
it's just very very a lot of detail you
know shout out to that crow joint that
you got like that
and of course anything or syrian you boy
i was i was definitely a fan of charles
of osiris armor the titans is
very litty right now but i got to shout
you out like i did
off off camera before we started it
can't
they carry me over cyrus choice with the
backpack
with the little eyes yeah that's right
what was the whole concept behind that i
think that's hilarious um
i mean obviously you know carry me
that was the and i think at the time um
i had went uh i went to the lighthouse
actually i lied i said i only been once
i've been twice i went
with my buddy lux and nova recently and
actually felt like i contributed on that
run
okay um but yeah it uh
what were you saying what was i saying
jeremy osiris
the backpack the creation yes so uh we
were talking one day in the thing i was
like thanks guys you never put me in
your backpack and i was like i should
make a i should make a
design you know like a trousers backpack
with little eyes peeking out like
being carried so that was just kind of
where that came from sometimes a lot of
my
my ideas just come from or designs come
from silly ideas
i love it yeah man clap i was rolling
man yo shout out to y'all again
not usually don't shout out a lot of
people's birds but the birch is fire bro
you got that
run dmc i
appreciated that but yeah it's a little
better if you guys you guys should check
it out man it's really
really cool stuff yeah thank you put the
link in the description
show them short people yeah
i was like i wanted to flip it
completely different because there's
something i didn't expect
so explain your love of astronomy i'm
actually very
curious about that because you said
that's kind of a hidden thing
for you how did that start and then like
how deep
are we talking you got like a minor in
astrophysics over here
i don't but uh astrology is uh
astronomy not astrology uh was the
single class
in college i was sad when it ended like
that's the only class i never wanted to
stop like it was just so fascinating
but i think my love for it i grew up in
north carolina fayetteville and uh
there's some pretty remote areas
out that way as you can imagine um and
one of my best friends
lived out in the the boonies the
woodworks and behind his house was this
giant cornfield where they would do corn
well um in the off season it was just a
giant open field
and it was pitch black out there you
could see the milky way all that stuff
so
myself along with a few friends of mine
we started going out
there just stargazing and we got a hold
of farmers almanac and we would look
when the meteor showers the annual ones
and we would plan
events and go out there and we just
started watching them
and um i started kind of self teaching
constellations and i you know we'd point
things out and then i started learning
about the planets and which ones i could
call out and different
all right so it kind of snowballed um
from that
and uh yeah i got a
i got to tell us a really nice telescope
um a couple years ago i think i had a
little rinky dink one for a while but i
i finally was like you know what i'm
gonna i'm gonna get a nice one
it's pretty cool like that um what was
that a recent they called it the
christmas
star where uh jupiter and was it
the venus in jupiter jupiter mars i
can't remember they were
talking about each other with um
yeah like in the same frame like and so
i got my telescope set up and it was so
cool to see
the two planets like side by side and
you can see the moons of jupiter around
that stuff but that's
incredible wow yeah so meteor showers
i'm a huge fan of that's
probably what sucked me in to all that
um
but definitely wanted to take astronomy
in
in college and i did and it was just i
mean stuff that will break your brain
like in there it's just
it's crazy like how our galaxy you know
when you back out and then the scale
of the universities that make a cluster
yeah you back out of that and there's
clusters that make giant super clusters
and you back out of that it
dude it's it's mind blowing your brain
breaks sometimes when
of the you're yeah picture i think
hubble took that was like very very long
exposure
and it's got like galaxies upon galaxies
and it's like it's some
giant i don't you've probably seen the
same one and it's just like jam-packed
full and you're like every one of these
little tiny things that you see with
like some little like color style
that's like a whole like milky way
situation going on and this is just like
a tiny piece of
it was pointed one much less the
infinite space around it's like
no when you start going in space
astronomy and how big the
the scale of it is it's like yeah we're
pretty damn tiny
yeah i mean every star in the sky is
literally a sun
in a solar system somewhere yep like
that's insane
you know yeah that's my very long answer
how i got it
oh i like it that's why i was like i
like space the space and science for
sure so
i don't know if you kept track recently
of the the mars landing and stuff like
that too
yep yeah that's where the wind
[Laughter]
i mean i know that's a breakthrough it's
a breakthrough not as dope man
really really cool stuff love that
aspect tremendous history the artwork is
fire loving that salute to them that
that that
choice too the one with the lament oh
yeah that's kind of one thing i wanted
to point out about your style is like
the very defined lines i guess is one
way
for me to phrase that and that's like
probably a poor description of how it's
phrased but
like like some look more like is that
line weight okay yeah it's like
i like using the thick bold lines and
yes changing the line weight and the um
and again i think it goes back to my
graphic
background you know like i've had people
describe my my style as graphic
and i never really thought about that
and uh because i like the bold clean
lines and that's how i painted my
graffiti too when i would do that i
i would take so much longer than
everyone else because i'm sitting there
like cleaning up
little booger spots of paint that no
one's gonna notice but
you want sitting there yeah you know
like you want that crisp just like clean
line yeah my
i wanted them to look like stickers yeah
yeah that's kind of how they looked
yeah that's a good description because
yeah it's like everything is so just
crisply defined like as you said the
banshee one is a huge stick out because
you see the sword
the way it looks and that one's just i
mean the lament itself just the sword of
the way it looks and like his helmet
when you go through the draw
ah it just it's so defined and but like
precise and
like there's so many artists in the
community you look around but like the
lines on yours i feel like are probably
the most predominant of
a lot of the artists i see which is kind
of a cool standout feature of yours i
like
thank you thank you very much so many
amazing artists it's
it's incredible oh yeah we've had a
couple on you guys
i'm still blown away by all of you guys
just did very each of you have your own
different way
yeah yeah i mean it was literally a
handful of us in like year one
i feel like a handful and like now it's
hundreds if not you know into the
thousand yeah
there's a lot of us now oh yeah
beautiful i'm constantly daily
seeing cool things tweeted like artwork
of destiny and
i will instantly follow instantly
retweet every single time
like i just i'm constantly like finding
new amazing
artists it's really good it's what's
that's really cool about the destiny
community in that respect you know
like i said all these unique talents and
and and the fact that bungie
you know promotes you know guys doing it
you know i mean so it's not like they
did it you know stopping people from
doing that and um
yeah man one thing about this community
is really cool is that the
artist community comes together
everybody sharing each other's stuff
it's a lot of love for them i love the
unique talent again when i came across
your art style i was like damn like this
is really
i see his his difference his unique
style with it you know what i'm saying
so thank you thank you
dope yeah no uh i mean obviously we'll
talk about outriders because i know
you've been a little busy with that i
saw on stream but obviously we're here
to talk about some destiny stuff that's
been going on
uh and this week we got a nice little
juicy [ __ ] to talk about we got some
changes coming
uh so the first piece obviously
isn't even on the twab it's like twitter
twitter has been hilarious with kyle
taking over bungie's
like destiny the game account and
actually responding to people
now apparently it's like canon i just
want to get you guys thoughts on that so
far what you've seen
yeah it's i wanted to see what you guys
thought if you liked it and you're like
this is kind of hilarious or is it like
now i'm confused
just curious like before we even get in
the game where you're at with a cop
i think it's cool you know
he's like that's it that's cool i was
like
i honestly thought it was funny because
there were a couple people that were
like
the whole thing where some people like
step on me which is still
just like kill killing me for whatever
reason i just find that like
ridiculously odd
but the fact that she responded to one
of those
was actually even better yes that's not
the name
title i think that's how it's said that
might be my next digital piece i might
try to
oh man
yeah don't mask the truth yeah i get
that
i'm just trying not to embrace the idea
of that that's all
yeah yeah i i get it same with the uh
what is the lady
i can't even pronounce her name the one
from resident evil 8.
lady d yeah nah i thought i thought it
was cool i thought it was um
i didn't know what was going on my
friend of mine had to tell me and i was
just like
it's like yes um kato took over the the
dusty account you know said i'm like
what did i like to go
myself and then i'm like they're
speaking in cato like what's going on
like she's talking to people
i think it was tassie that says
something he's like yo she responded to
me
like am i canon now like what's going on
like from a story standpoint so i
thought let's they're having fun with it
i think at the end of the day like i've
been preaching
you know destiny's story right now a
narrative team
is probably on fire this is the hottest
i've seen them
you know and i want to continue to give
them you know the credit because i know
we always
complain and you know people that don't
play destiny always did the running
jokers oh it has no story and i'm saying
this
you know kind of stuff but the narrative
leads and then
it's like a little episode i tune in you
know every week to see what's going to
happen obviously we have the big thing
with uh with crow and um you know osiris
and zavala you know what i'm saying with
more always a violent crow to be honest
but you know
it it is i think like i said bye said it
best like
is it like the greatest thing ever but
this no but it's still more for
improvement
but this is probably their peak from a
narrative standpoint so to see them have
fun
with their twitter account and get it
and just embrace the character and
praise the villain
why not why not like let's have fun with
it so i'm about it man
i'm really again i've been very hard on
the narrative team
ever since we did last work you know you
know it
i always want narrative continuity i
want transitions between seasons
i want all this stuff and they're kind
of doing it you know what i'm saying
they kind of
in in a covet era so salute to them
having fun and just continuing this
channel
i like it yeah the one that i call out
is the one that dakota said in chat and
they're like do you
regret what was it do you regret
betraying your father callus and they're
like do you regret not being able to
save caves i was like damn they went
there
i was like oh man i was like
holy crap so like they went all in with
the title which was
really really cool but that one i was
like damn they went they went deep that
was a deep cut
but no like you kind of brushed over but
that was honestly we've i've said it
multiple weeks and like
this week log in we get to see
like the storyboard animated
animated assassination attempt
i know it was like they heard me talking
they heard me
i still haven't yet to see that cut
scene i don't know what triggers it but
i haven't so you have to be far enough i
don't know
i've heard i know all about yeah to just
see it basically you just have to be far
enough in the quest progression like the
weekly
quest that you've got to do at the war
table you just have to do that that's
all
yeah is that a pro crow quest line no
it's just at the war table
it's basically like go do a yeah yeah go
do a couple things go to a battleground
like it's
yeah basic but it kind of continues that
progression that one yes okay
okay but yeah we got to see like zavala
sitting there spending time in the
garden chilling he gets the
hallucination which he figured out was
not a hallucination
turns fires the gun on the scion we're
like okay they tried
and then that's i think what really
spawned kyle taking over twitter saying
hey if i wanted to kill zavala i'd do it
with like looking into his eyes and i
was like
okay that's a warrior's mentality but
also means somebody's like
basically yeah somebody's disobeying
stepping out like
she did free the scions to be now
not like slaves basically which is a
good thing for
i guess the psions because that's how
they were treated before so she as
you know the cabal empress kind of freed
the scions to be
kind of of their own will but that also
means there's
a question of who's doing it and what's
going on which overall is like
that was really like this week i logged
in was like
yes i was just like i was so pumped i
would have watched you too i thought
i was like listening to me how could
it be if every reset they had a
different character from the game
running the twitter
that would be pretty dude like two comes
in so fun for a week
i don't even think about that like yo
because it's dope
it just what it is it's all about you
know cohesion
and attachment emotional attachment and
i think what it is is
you know kaido is definitely a very
intricate polarizing figure but a very
interesting a very different
type of leader you know what i mean and
the thing that i like about that is if
they continue to do this and maybe you
get one week you get let you know zavala
you know i would love to hear salad it
is in his bag right now oh
dude silent is about forget all this
they try to assassinate my mans let's
bring it to them
i want to destroy them all like
is on this murder them all we're not
there's no more peace treaties it's
right
i hate to spoil this stuff for you
because i know you haven't caught up yet
but
it is very interesting everyone has like
their whole
you know this thing even of amanda right
she had to check them she's like yo
fam we're not invaders we are guardians
like calm down
oh if we you know such what they have
like he's in his bag right now it is
there are peak storytelling moments and
i love it from the voice acting
to to like i said this weekly thing with
the helm and now to the twitter accounts
it's really been fun for me man a lot of
fun now this is
again the best i've seen it from them as
a group very
interactive yeah this is set in a bar
that is
honestly like they got to keep this up
and if this is something like
kind of a preview for what they want to
do with witch queen
oh sign me up man this is that's
exciting because
they want to go bigger and better for
which queen and you're like
this is the season what the hell are you
gonna do with an expansion like holy
crap that's a orcs's daughter right
which
is his sister so sabbath is one of the
three wait for
his grandma to come in
we're taking out that family tree yeah
that whole tree is getting chopped down
so far like we're like we were dealing
with zevo
wrath and hunt like she's still one of
those like savathun's playing
big old big ass puppet master oryx is a
floating stone somewhere out there by
saturn
but yeah no that family tree has
definitely had some struggles we took
out
oryx's two daughters the like two which
like the two witches we took out his son
crota we've been going we've been going
ham on that family tree it's pretty
sister
hash ladoon or crota's daughter hashtag
alice's daughter yeah we have we've
messed up some families we have yeah
we're gonna bring jerry springer we
gotta have some talks celestial home
wreckers is what guardians like
we are we are breaking breaking up
families in here it's fine
we are salute but yeah that was a huge
standout for me just when you logged in
i was like oh the cut scene
the twitter account all the stuff has
been really fire so
so far yeah storytelling just absolutely
crushing it
yeah now in game obviously we're getting
a little bit of battleground
stuff going on uh that kind of continues
to be the seasonal activity i wanted to
kind of get you guys thoughts now as
we're on
what is this like week five i think
challenge five how are you guys feeling
on the seasonal activities so
far now cop you got a chance
you haven't got a chance much this
season right it's been yeah yeah
i i haven't been on a whole lot this
season i i've been able to get
um i got the you know the the hawk moon
i can't remember if that was the season
or last
but the uh got the dead no man's hand
dead man's tail yep that's the season
thank you yeah i got that and then i
went through it again and got
one re-roll with uh vorpal so i thought
oh nice pretty good
oh but that that's about
it um i get on with my girlfriend who
strikes and like the pinnacle weekly
stuff but i
i haven't got to really sink my teeth
into a lot of the new season which is
unfortunate because it ends in like what
is it next week or a couple weeks i
don't know it seems like you're on week
now well the season ends on like may
10th so you got like two months you're
fine
okay to your question um
it was more about like how am i feeling
about the seasonal activity and just
the cadence that kind of thingy that was
your question
kind of the cadence of like the well a
couple pieces first was just like the
activities like how are battlegrounds
feeling for you
five weeks in now as opposed to like
first week
all right so here's i got some pluses
and now for my first minuses
i like the season i do like the season
however um i mean let's start with the
pluses
i like the varied battlegrounds i do
i do feel that each of them are unique
in a cool way probably my favorite is
probably
cosmodrome just for pure hecticness and
i feel like the
cabal are kind of like making a little
fort and trying to hold it down and then
you got
a hive in the mix and it's like it's
like this cross battle and the guardians
just interfering like they're just
in their business and they shouldn't be
there um the
europa one is cool you know what i'm
saying i like the end of the europa one
i i feel again where battlegrounds is
where i love it
is pure chaos from all
angles and then the dope thing they do
is when the boss is at that final
click he like all lagoons come out of
the earth
they surround them they bring out the it
they bring out everything
it's it's cool because you can then use
all of your power tricks all your builds
all your stuff to combat it
so it's pure chaos love that aspect the
thing
i'm not liking right is the okay
obviously the hammer upgrading thing the
time gaining of that is a bit of a noise
right these are my least favorite things
in this yeah
and here's my thing i like what they're
trying to do with the focal engram stuff
on the tier three
it's way too many hammer charges to get
one like i gotta get what is it
what is it four or five one three and
then five yeah yeah
so i gotta get five to get the tier
three
right then when you unlock the the
hammer joint like
they're forcing you to be in there like
you got to run it so many times
if you want to consistently form and i'm
at the point now
where the activity is formed but if you
want me to run it like nine
times just to get it's like fair this is
way too much right so now you're making
an activity i like
redundant like too much
like that that's what i feel like i
literally it's like
it's like wearing on me i'm like damn
because i just want to get
like four or five hammer charges let my
boy go down there i want to farm the
cold dweller rocket
and by the way i got to complain right
now my rng i know we're dealing with an
rng guard right now with my man
but all i want is to farm is cold dwello
e
i run like nine battlegrounds i finally
get the charge
and they keep giving me the damn linear
fusion rifle and i'm going to
go crazy bro just with frenzy i was
gonna say
shout out to it might be error which we
gotta work on getting on here shout out
if you ever listen
but um honestly and this
is i don't want to hijack it from you
but i'm about to so
no i'm fully to the point where for me
umbrals are
just not feeling great nuisance
i agree yeah it's like so the idea of an
umbrella well for one his thing is like
don't go for a tier two or two three
just do a tier one
because the time and effort you take to
go for tier three or tier five
two things can happen when you go for
tier one just go for a chosen
item yeah and you and you it only takes
one charge
right so you got your like list of six
weapons and
you know you can either do one charge
and get
you know one weapon and then go so then
you literally get chance at five weapons
or you can get one weapon
still get the wrong thing but if you do
the five you get five rolls
five weapons and some of the other
weapons might be god rules of the other
things even if you don't get those so
it's like
the idea that you're at a point where
you don't want to do tier 2 and tier 3
because it's
not worth your time that is a problem
because
for one it takes so long to unlock yeah
like you got 700 on the first one and i
get that
fine give me an option to just go after
just the rocket if you as you said
if you go two even on tier three if you
go two
or if you go five and you go oh i got
two perks of the final thing
of a linear fusion rifle sucks and
that's literally you have to go through
and do
at least one more before you burn it out
and the other thing is
we gotta yeah in front like these
battlegrounds are not short activities
no
these joints take time like you'll be in
there for a minute mixing it up so it's
like it's the time
investment to then not get get exactly
what you want and i think
peak of it what was what was when
umbro's debut are we going to say
season of arrivals which one uh yeah
drifter i felt that was better you know
i'm saying the weight of hand like this
one
you make you make a good point if ever
said that i might have to do that just
go for the
the the weapon and just keep form so
that it's
out of a choice of of weapons as opposed
to this
tier three maybe you get it after all
that it's not worth well the other worst
part is the armor
like if you go for an armor and i was
like cool let me go for one with
intellect
i got a 54 stat roll yes
54 stat roll for a tier three
five hammer charge i'm like what the i
i was like what the hell oh it was three
tier three was 54 stat total oh
no we're not doing that much like the
whole like
high stat roll that they think is like
56 61 plus
i'm sorry there is enough rng in that
stat department distribution already
it could be like tens across the board
it could be spiky in the wrong places
there's enough other things that can go
wrong so try and get one thing
right and you're like i want intellect
okay
you get 22 and like mobility you'll
bother
and then you'll get like two two two and
it's still a 54 and you're like
this is awful this is like complete
trash like let's not act like they
asking us to kill like a
thousand things just to unlock the tier
three oh yeah you gotta kill you gotta
stay with that weapon and and kill for a
thousand kills just and i'm just like
come on
the tier three weapons are 2100 kills
yeah like for that
investment i better be getting some 64 5
or higher with some
you know what i'm saying like i'll feed
you yes 62 at a minimum and it's just
like
so the armor burned me and i was like i
tried one arm i was like all right let
me see if i can get some minute like i
got 54 is like never doing that again
ever
that alone tells you your system's wrong
like if that's not worth the time for me
to do that no
now if they make i honestly would much
rather put my time
into like all nine charges
yeah knowing because also the other
pieces you want a piece high in
intellect
but you can't pick which piece so the
tier above you can pick
helmet that's that the one below you can
pick that if i could go tiered
and now granted it would have to be 61
or up to make it worth my while but if i
could go
if you want a helmet with intellect and
i can really start going after a build
for nine
yeah that'd be burned me out too but at
least at that point i could be very
focused on
hey i got some decent slots here but if
i do want to just like complete this
build
with a high intellect helm take my nine
charges or whatever the hell you can get
up to
but that would be at least something
because you either do one or the other
but you can't focus both
so then again the grind has enough rng
you go intellect
okay now you have stat rules
distribution
and then slot yeah and then multiply all
that together and it's got
a ridiculous number as usual so it's
like the the whole umbral system
for me is not hitting and definitely
needs some love
but it's like also but yeah also i'm
back into this he's loving it
he's loving all this great rng we talk
about right
but i was like but that as you said the
other side of umbrals is like cool i
want to go after this one thing
then you spent all the time in
battlegrounds you kind of worn out and
then you get the crap roll and it's like
you just kind of ruined two things at
the same time it's like battlegrounds
which can be cool
they're kind of grindy and like yeah
i've upgraded the hammer so now i get
two charges every time
i get a chance at three which hasn't
happened that often
but even if it's that it's um
it's just like yeah if you do you know
three three four battlegrounds probably
at a minimum maybe five to get up there
that adds up that's like a good almost
hour hour and 20 minutes maybe an hour
and a half depending on your timing of
things you're like hour and a half
wasted cop what you thinking about all
this man yeah
um could you guys explain something to
me about
uh said hammers yeah so the first one i
think that's why i'm
stagnant on my quest because i
i ranked up a hammer i did that i went
to the battlegrounds i
you know summoned the whatever well
after i beat them the you know the three
chest pops
slam whatever it told me to do it again
you charged up my hammer and i did like
50 battlegrounds and not once did the
chest thing happen again so i don't know
what i'm missing
so the chest needs to be done in the
battlegrounds playlist
right so like the chest that you smash
with the hammer
yeah if you select on like the
cosmodrome director and you take it
direct
the chests aren't there which is weird
in my opinion
the battlegrounds like selection in the
vanguard because it'll be like
nightfalls and battlegrounds
over here that's where the triple chest
and they say that nowhere
yeah so that's one of those weird things
that's like not obvious exactly
oh you've been on a planet surrounding
them directly no no
oh yeah yeah you gotta go do a
battleground
okay here's one yeah
well i also can't tell you like so if
you switch your medallion you don't get
your gold back so that's wasted like
there goes how many strikes and stuff
that you've done
yeah um and then what's there's one
other piece i was trying to think of for
an issue on well then it's the other
side is like then you eventually will
hit your wall
now you gotta go grind strikes or gambit
or crucible
to get your gold back up and it's just
like
the surprisingly the gold part hasn't
bothered me i usually get that so like
what i did is i increased my goal
capacity
you know i'm saying but i'm up to 70.
it's still just yeah
i'm updating but it's like i know what
you mean but again it's just like you
said
it's one of those things where the the
the way this little loop is going is
just not
it's not clean you know what i'm saying
and it just it makes it redundant when
it shouldn't be and again the activity
is
is not short this is this this is a time
investment activity so
for that time investment you want to be
rewarded better and they got to do a
better job
so finally i'm like i was liking this
and
now that i've gotten deeper i'm like
still needs work
that experience you're talking about i
had that with breakneck
i used to love me some gambit yeah um
but when i had to do
what 50 matches yeah in a row yeah
what was it this week the challenge one
of the seasonal challenges
is infamy ranks they're worded ranks so
you literally have to reset your infamy
you have to go from zero to 15 000 or
reset it at legend
now this is like double maybe triple
started today so like it's a good week
to work on it
but if you're working and you
technically have all season to do it
that's still a lot of gambit because if
you are playing against
there's no freelance playlist and if you
get paired up against people that like
spawn a boss and nuka boss
you're lost yeah yeah ain't no way at
least it's faster
now i mean it is faster i will give you
that and i played some like i won some i
lost them today chat was there earlier
with me and i was like
let's play some gambit because i got to
work on this we won some we lost one
dano jumped in there a little bit to
help me out and we were playing but
there sometimes we were like hey we
tried
and then just the boss tells us yeah
for me i don't think i'm ever going to
get dredging because i waited too long
and now with what is it that one thing
where they want you to get 75 modes or
something
with how quick it is and lack of rounds
like i think that's down to 50 now they
did change that for dredging i believe
okay because i'm like bro i'm never
gonna get that yeah i was gonna say like
honestly what you need to do recruit
some buddies
run together and let you pick them up
yeah that's i mean if you got
friends on some playlists like two or
three people playing together
they don't pick any you just have to be
the one to pick them up somehow get a
four stack with you and they just like
they kill everything you run around pick
them up and dunk that's your whole job
and that's your one way to do that and
that's again like take a solo person
playing
that's next to impossible like if you're
yeah if you're with a group and you
don't know him you're never gonna get
that done
never gonna get that done never gonna
get that i agree i agree you have to ask
that's a controlled you know what i'm
saying
task just to to coordinate i just get it
but uh yeah
i agree i agree like i said that that
part needs work
what else we get oh and then yeah new
red sand down the road the challenges
want you to kill 40 guardians in gambit
a lot of invading so again it's like do
i work on it now
right or do i yeah i know my internet
popped in and outside there sorry guys
on the connection um
but yeah it's like that's for gambit
kind of being shrunk a little bit but no
new maps not much changes
and there's really only one gun that
everybody wants in there at the bottom
there's a fusion but
i don't even want to worry about that
one that's a whole lot of gambit they
want you to play
for not much really that has changed
with the mode
right i would have got fallout maxed his
gambit he
like maxed it and didn't get one uh
bottom dollar drop
yeah and if he did that i think he did
it sooner than uh infamy so his was a
slow grind
yeah yeah uh but yeah also this
this coming week we've got a they had a
preview comment or a patch kind of
update on tuesday so we've got the
preview coming for a couple
things changing next week we've got the
grand masters coming so as usual
max power cap is 13.25 you can't be
above it because you're capped but
they're actually at 13.50
so artificial difficulty fun go ahead
and be be squishy uh each strike will
have a specific set of modifiers we know
that one grand master will be available
each week
on april 20th this line people had way
too much fun with
that's 420 for those of you guys who
didn't pick that one up you'll have the
opportunity to blaze through
all available grand master nightfalls
through a direct launch playlist and i
was like
well i do believe they are in washington
so that one hits you know spot on
i gotta call them out they used that one
last year oh they did
oh they use it blaze a path or something
like that
and you remember it distinctly
yeah exact same blaze your way to so
somebody's recycling dylan
or i think dmg wrote this one
um but yeah final three weeks you'll be
able to work on them this will now allow
you to get your chances to get your
adept pve weapons
so we're gonna have a chance that our
adept shadow price adept palinderome and
adept swarm
uh swarm being at least a arc
machine gun which you don't have a ton
of those running around i just need to
get a normal one i will tell you i've
run
not a ton of nightfalls and they've been
a little lower difficulty
i've literally got zero of these weapons
so far in my normal runs i don't have a
shadow price palindrome or swarm
i got one calendar on them and the euro
now
i think it was yeah i was gonna say now
some people are saying that like you
know the higher difficulty if you do
master or at least legend at like
13 10. whatever like the bump up is
the non-match made one at 1300 i think
some people are staying decent
but i was like i was doing like the hero
one but i've done enough like
grinding for running a chance run a few
every so often still to have zero
between all these weeks that's kind of
getting a little ridiculous
one extra legendary item go on your
ghost that is what
can help i got about two or three shadow
prices but
nothing else i ever got the power jerome
and i haven't gotten
one i just want a decent swarm probably
don't care too much about the other two
personally yeah i agree i'm with you i'm
saying that he said shadow price needs
to be at 600 rpm yeah
i wish you were 450 450. yeah shadow
price that's what like swarm's the only
one i really want
like i don't even know what care it's
just an arc machine gun so i just kind
of want it
absolutely um but yeah it's like are you
when you kind of get into running with
your crew are either of you guys
grandmaster
runners do you guys ever get into that
uh myself probably not yeah um
i do like challenging things and every
now and again i'll grab pale or someone
if if i mean i might go for a shadow
price i don't know i'm a big ar guy but
um
i don't know hey the loot i i guess the
the loot doesn't uh outweigh the
frustration for me
or something you know some of those i
might give them a try here and there but
you know
some of those bullet spongy ones i just
the fun gets sucked out of it for me
you know i have uh
i'm kind of waiting a copy i've yet to
run a grand master
i've yet again to me you know i just
felt
before a debt weapons were introduced
that
the incentive to do that for charles and
a golf ball was not anything i was
interested in
so it's like that ain't happening for me
i'm sorry you know grand master i'm
running
in the record player exactly
i'm like don't push me i'll get my
presents and
golf balls the old-fashioned way i'm
good you know now they they
introduced this and you look the adap
stuff is
is a carrot you know some people are
very interested again from
still got enough for me per se you know
what i'm saying like you know the plus
whatever
handling and whatever whatever and i
think maybe it's because
these i'm sorry if i've upset anybody
these three particular weapons although
they are classic but they do not do
anything for me really you know i'm
saying um
machine guns are not in a good place for
me to go crazy for that's just me
oh literally the only one i care about
typically
it's like ever since i've been mad at
bungie with machine guns and linear
fusion rifles for a while
yeah and it's like fam i love what you
did with rocket launchers
rocket launchers in a great place now
you gave that overall was it 30
buff oh yeah but linear man and again
shout out that we talked about him
earlier i got
to shout him out error he's got a good
video like even with linear is like
the best new ones the new one that's out
now you know even if you put vorpal on
it
and frenzy or whatever clown like
the best possible roles you get the
damage output the dps is not
good at all so it's like they still got
they just need that slight bump
and for me these three archetypes
outside of palindrome i want to get
power drum i want to see how that is i
have not touched that
but outside yeah shout out yo noob said
it the exact same thing
apart from paul jones nothing really is
good and powerful good only because of
thank you that
so for me i you're not getting me to go
in there and get
slightly slapped just by getting that
and that level of difficulty
and being you know angry i'm not gonna
put myself through that level of
frustration for
in my opinion mediocre weapons with some
archetypes that are not great
now trials they did a good thing like
they put messenger in it that's a great
archetype
that hard-hitting desperado unique perks
you know what i'm saying kind of thing
we're not even seeing any uh i mean
correct me if i'm wrong e like is there
any
oh look while you talk but i don't know
of many i'm not even seeing any
combinations that could be exciting and
i'm like yo i would want
you know a swarm with x y and z
combination
combination that that's god tear or
whatever like
none of that stuff i'm not i'm sorry
literally like for your perks in both
columns when you look at swarm for
example which is one i might be excited
about
killing wind outlaw dynamic sway
reduction surplus
zen moment slide ways tap the trigger
one for all dragonfly and portable
like they're fine but there's nothing
and that's the kind of the thing that's
burned
like kind of burned me a little bit with
this stuff too is
like i was lucky enough shout out to
silver spear and
am so sorry i forgot his name but like
those two basically dragged my hind
quarters through
conquer they did like two days i forgot
your name
shout out to you honestly yeah like you
would have to look up the gentleman who
helped
yeah both of them were they were awesome
now
it's like it's the issue with like the
grand masters i haven't been doing the
pinnacles that hard
you have to be 325 but you don't get any
benefit for being higher
i am like 13 16 right now i think my
pinnacle grind hasn't been crazy i've
been raiding as much and i know that's
where you get most of it
but it was like shout out to that dude
y'all are killing me i am sorry i was
like i apologize forget forgetting
dude you know that dude yes thank you
all in chat you guys are killing me he
will change his name
anyway
y'all are killing me um
shout out to that dude yes but that's
kind of the thing is like
the like precision level it took to go
through
the like punishment level the
i mean granted it's a time thing right
now you can either go artifact to 20 and
get
some pinnacles to like plus five
your honestly better benefit is to
actually get your pinnacles to plus 10
so your weapons hit harder because then
the artifact is only doing some of it
but it's like as you guys said the the
punishment for the average person to go
through for grand master
is not worth the adept version for sure
if i can get even a normal version of a
swarm that's got a decent roll
the adept is not going to set itself
apart enough especially in a pv
activity like pvp you have like small
differences that'll make a difference
because they try and keep it fairly
balanced
but in pve just like crazier is better
so the fact that it's like smaller
nuanced like
do i really give a damn if a swarm has
like like
master worked reload speed that's like
plus three more a couple
i'm never gonna feel it you could put me
two computers side by side
this one's a depth this one's not i
would never know a difference and i
honestly would be hard-pressed to know a
lot of people that could be like
that's the adept and be right probably
more than half the time
i agree i think to me what is a more
exciting carrot
is what um they did with uh
the tier three what you call it which is
give us the extra perk combination of
choice health too yeah
that you know what i'm saying because
one thing i like about that is that
let's be real sometimes you farm
and you're like damn i really wanted
this perk but i i like
the the extra perk choice it gives you
versatility
especially especially extra rng if you
missed out especially two chances to get
a
one one perk that you really want you
know not that part i really like
for sure so yeah
they still got it the depth still needs
work
to again it's all about respecting
uh effort and time you know i mean like
let me ask you as the pvp person or for
either of you guys like
the times you've gone through for trials
the time like the amount of effort it
takes to get through trials
right and say you already have a
messenger with desperado on it
do you care enough to go after the
flawless
adept version i only cared when
summoner adept was around i definitely
fought for that bad boy but that was
what destiny won yeah i was d1
yeah i was fired that's fine so nothing
really in d2 i don't think
um uh i mean i want to try the hand
cannon out
yeah i want to get that yes yes shout
out to lux
and if he's trying to charge shout out
to him you know
yeah i mean for me it was um
first the auto was it i'm looking at
them right now yeah something like you
said
and then um obviously messenger i still
got a igneous
look i have i have the incentive to go
in there
you know i'm saying to to rock out for
the weapons but
it's one of those things where again the
the actual lighthouse
you know getting getting that weapon i
think the problem i'm having again this
is another uh
this is a good question because the
problem i'm having is the same thing
they're doing with iron banner right now
i don't like this new thing where it's
like yo we're gonna give you iron gaze
whatever it is plus you know 55 range
but minus 65 this
is a perk stop taking something away
from you know what i'm saying like
because it makes it unattractive i was
spoken to kaibab so he got like this
crazy thing but it like
like nerfed the range all the way but it
gave him all the stability and i just
hate this push-pull
plus minus thing there's no incentive
for me to now
go get a mod that it's not just a
straight buff like that's what it should
be like it should be a straight buff
i know they're so scared about balance i
get it i know but if you're putting
people through this hell
of a death the nightfall of a lighthouse
run
like these things need to be significant
better i'm sorry like they need to be
like
they gotta they worry about us we lost
cop but um
yeah that's my only thing man i just
really hope
you know they get back to that because
you know this
minus stuff is just it's very
it doesn't feel goody like it really
does especially like the perk
combination stuff
like that that's where i'm at but would
you think
yeah no i mean that's the same thing for
me too and hopefully we'll get caught
back in here soon yeah
i'm trying yeah all right we're here we
are yeah we're here we hear you uh
but like that's i mean the mods for me
too when i saw some of those were gonna
be
there we go we're back the mods with
even a little give and take on adept is
just like how do you do that
how can you even uh like you're gonna go
through
all of that pain in hell now granted
here would be one way to do it like
so you have the nightfalls now starting
to have adept mods potentially drop
right have some adept mods that do
combatants only or whatever qualifies as
enemies of the darkness whatever you
know
item they used to use and be like hey
when playing in
you know non-crucible activities or
whatever
or against non-guardians this has
then they could do things a little more
over the top because that kind of leads
into the sandbox thing we'll talk about
here soon
of splitting sandboxes because what if
you got a perk where it was like
hey this adapt this adept mod will
double your magazine size
in pve right like that'd be like
150 bullets on like a mag in like a
machine gun magazine then it'd be like
okay now we might talk a little a little
like it needs to be something to that
level where pve
can shine especially as it's a pve
activity not like
here's a smidge more stability handling
reality like i'm not gonna feel it it's
not gonna do enough it's not tangible
and the last one i'll make is on my
before i get back to cop
is um you know the intrinsic
from the pvp side i'm going to beat it
down ad nauseum celerity needs to be in
trouble
intrinsically so at least the debt
version should have that oh right 100
percent
version should have that because that is
a specific
perk if my fire team's down you know i
get
you know this bonus range and all these
categories or bonus thing in all these
categories
that does not feel good as a perk
wasting a slot
at least they should have made that in
the depth so yeah again
intrinsic celebrity i want i love uh
final perk double perk choice you know
what i'm saying then you could throw
your little mod on it on top if they
want to play the little plus around this
game okay fine
but it needs to be an abundance of
riches
you know what i'm saying like not just
that you know so they still
still got a ways to go there when it
comes to this adapt stuff i'm
not all the way and that's one thing why
i wanted to turn it over to and i guess
we can just literally do this now
is i want to ask cobb why has
outrighters kind of thunk its teeth into
you a little bit
what what is what has kind of got you
excited about that so far
it's funny because that is actually a
really good segue it's
um it the combat's really satisfying in
it for me but um
i think it's the weapons and all the
abilities like you
i got a shotgun when you shoot people
they start floating in the air for five
seconds
think about how you know you got your
boys lined up get ready for these head
shots and you're running boom boom
boom hitting them and they're just
floating headshots
and like uh yeah just the abilities the
guns there's
a gun you shoot people and lightning
comes down out of the sky and it's just
constant
it doesn't have to proc on a headshot
everything's like
over the top like you just feel like a
beast
you know so i'm pretty excited for the
full release um
definitely nothing will ever be a
destiny killer but it will be a destiny
filler
that's good i like the i like the i like
the name
and i'm with you guys on the whole plus
minus thing there's nothing
worse than being like dude look at this
it's all cool if i put this up wait
takes 89
oh god boss with one kill you know and
take 99 you're super
it's the same thing with stasis minus
this you're going to give you extra
super energy but you go minus your
intellect we go
minus i'm like come on let me rock yeah
pvp should be
wide open we should feel like just
badasses i mean we do
we use our space magic but still you
know it's like but after
playing out writers and dakota said it
is like it makes you feel powerful and
i've said this
we've all probably said it countless
times destiny
typically doesn't make you feel that
powerful like you can
do what oh where they do they nerf yeah
it's like oh this is fun
too many people were having fun
that yeah good but it's like
but that's kind of the thing i took my
technomancer for example in outriders
and i'm running yes
in here i mean i've played all four i
have like 54 hours in the demo so i've
played them all
how many legendaries three
oh there you go we'll talk about i
haven't been farming
farming yes you haven't been farming as
hard i've been doing like content and
other things here but i was like i put a
decent amount of time in i got three
um but that's the thing i took the
blighted rounds and i was like i
honestly hadn't used it that much it was
the toxic crowns
and then i literally took to where like
the combination was
every kill you get while blind rounds is
active refills your magazine 30
it's like all right then i have an extra
extra magazine that counts and then when
i'm done with the
the done with the ability then it heals
my entire team a chunk of the damage
that i did over the course of that
so like blighted rounds is beast and
that's the thing i was like it took one
of one ability that i was like
and i'm like i felt like a trickster i
didn't
use cover once with my technomancer
because i'm just like running through
getting a bunch of kills damage i didn't
even stop and i'm just like
jesus there's offense in that game oh
it's huge
yeah that's correct that's massive and
something else it's like they took
all the like things other games needed
to have
and put them in there it's like quality
of your lifestyle what is your body
yes as soon as your body hits the floor
your respawn right there
all your super energy all your weapons
all your ammo all your grenade like
everything instantly you're not sitting
there going
three seconds on the cooldown
come on man it just it just gives it to
you like here have fun with these badass
weapons and like
yeah if you die on the boss right now
the full game those big creatures and
all that stuff yeah if you die on the
boss like on goss like oh i'm working on
farming him you die
you respawn right outside the door full
up everything ready to go like
you don't have to wait go ahead you're
just gone and you're like sweet
and there's so much there's the little
the auto loot button oh my god yes
that is amazing and how about
multi-marking your loot so you can
delete it all with one button
oh man that took some games a long
oh my awesome out to gene
dropping the love in chat thank you very
much appreciate the love tonight
uh he hasn't been in here in a minute
but she always definitely comes in with
an entrance so love love you thank you
the building but yeah it's like the
little stuff the the auto deleting the
selling the way the currencies have gone
like the mods the crafting system
honestly i feel like there's a lot of
people who don't know how much that
crafting system is gonna do
like the way you can take a legendary
tier three you're gonna if you break it
down because i actually have a duplicate
of one
so you break it down you unlock the tier
three in the tier two mod and i have
another legendary gun with the tier
three and tier two
take the tier three mod when you put a
tier three mod
in the other slot now you have two or
three in both
and guess what you can do that like with
every different little combination
you're like oh this one does like
so amazing that's yeah so i was like
i know that's going to give me kind of
the over-the-top feel but when the game
is rewarding to like that goofy level
now that also probably tells you world
tier 15
especially when you go into like
expeditions for the end game you're
probably gonna need some bonkers crazy
stuff to
handle it so i was like that's why it's
got to be there but that's
that's the pve side that i want and that
kind of takes it into
the sandbox changes we've finally got
when it comes to stasis and you've got
a whole bunch that say pve blank r
unchanged and that's huge so
cog i don't know if you got it up and
want to take us through but i know
sandbox is kind of
kind of always a little bit of your
wheelhouse so if you want to take us
through mostly the stasis stuff we've
got like
armor and devil's lair and some bugs
fixed but i was like i think the big
change for a lot of people is the stasis
so
i wanted to get your thoughts on these
straight to the stasis preview yeah
yeah so pretty much they jump in and
they were like look um they made some
targeting changes to stasis
and 12 they wanted to see how they
landed before making any more
adjustments now that we have several
weeks of data to airlines because you
know they love their data
to make some further changes to address
additional pain points
of stasis in pvp
i love that action puncture yourself
so they say oh here we go they said our
goal with these changes to reduce some
frustration
uh and they said we're fighting against
stasis subclass to the crucible while
maintaining their power in pve content
whether possible
with that said some changes required us
to adjust the global behavior of some
abilities
in the patch notes below we've
explicitly mentioned which changes will
affect crucible functionality only
so they start to go into it so we start
with hunter
shatter dive remove damage resistance
from shatter dive added a four
second cooldown between activations of
shadow dive then we got withering blade
decreased
withering blade damage against players
from 1965 damage
pve damage unchanged
decreased weather and blade slow attacks
applied to players from 60 to 40 stacks
pve slow attacks i even honestly found
withering blade weak in pvp i don't i
dude the only time i've ever killed
somebody was that is when they had like
two percent of their health left
you throw it it doesn't even their
shield hardly like i don't know what
this whole
like we have got to fix this there's a
lot of people that will go
throw in a dinner plate or something so
the idea with withering blade is some
people can go double melees
for 180 damage which will almost kill
them and it's just dank data
so that's why like people were yeah at
that point
they was running that double melee
killing me decrease the target
acquisition range of withering blade
after it impacts a player for 12 minutes
eight meters
range after pve enemies is unchanged
e i want to give you the titan though oh
really are we doing this it's your
people
my people wow you're one of those guys
we mentioned titan and he started
flexing the guns
literally he didn't even know he was
doing it yeah
i was scratching the back of my head i
don't know what you're talking about
okay so glacial quake now granted i will
say all of these perks there were people
i saw on twitter
who are a lot more like pvp centric than
i am ascendant nomads the fallouts the
drewskis all of like literally ascended
nomad literally took every one of these
green check green check green like so
many people who are very pvp focused
were
very happy about these perks so honestly
like it's really cool to see bungie nail
so many of them with what a lot of
people wanted they almost got like
not perfect like for a few people it
wasn't enough for all the way but they
did a lot of things well
to hopefully like not kill him but bring
him in
yeah so titans glacial quake that's your
super the first they remove the aoe
freeze against
players on cast will still freeze pve
again
good thing there they did reduce the
damage resistance from 60
to 50 that still
that's going to be everywhere so you're
gonna be a little weaker increase the
energy cost of using shiver strike which
is basically your melee while you're in
glacial quake from three percent to
seven percent
main reason behind that now that's one
of those i wish they would like
i have like something in my eye um i
wish
that could be a separate pve thing
because like giving a little more
mobility because some i will tell you
like as i've gone for my fragment
quests on my titan i'll usually do those
in gambit it's like get super kills
i get that's the longest thing for me
yeah because as a titan to get super
kills for some reason it feels like it
takes forever
mostly because it just doesn't seem to
you don't get the kills you freeze them
and then you like kind of fly around and
punch but they never seem to count for
i swear it's like a bug um so there's
that using the combo of shiver strike
into a heavy slam will now cost the full
super energy for both the shiver strike
and the slam
so apparently people are like flying and
then slamming to do
both and still save some of the super
energy and then there's that also shiver
strike increase the downwards velocity
applied to shiver striking players
when they are slowed to pull them out of
the air so i guess if i like shiver
struck a floating warlock you'd fall to
the ground faster is that the idea the
way i read okay yeah
so the big thing for me there is
mostly they're trying like apparently
titans are just walking around kind of
op and they could travel the entire map
back and forth is the general idea so
it's like they're bringing a lot of that
in check a little lower damage
resistance not the instant freeze can't
travel quite as far
still gonna be able to do a decent
amount of things in a normal area but
you won't be able to go map to mapside
so
it seems fair but i was like but i will
still stay as like when i have those
frustrations and gave it when i'm like
i need a little more time to get kills
because sometimes things just don't
register that could be a bug
but i was like there are a couple things
in here that are just general i wish
they could have been pvp only but that's
just me
i'll jump into the locks but um also in
your defense with the whole umbral
thing the fragment stuff is um
the i think they made at the end of this
patch notes that they're going to
decrease those requirements they felt
those requirements were a bit too
you know lengthy and unfair so i think
that's also coming to help you out now
because i i agree with you i feel a lot
of the umbrella stuff
you know for stasis like it really drags
on something like for me to slow kill
sometimes take long
a lot of things but let me get into the
locksmith see what's going on my people
oh winter's red improved tracking of
winter's wrath projectiles
now tracking strength decays from its
max value over 10 seconds instead of
2.2 seconds thank god little turret
isn't stupid anymore
oh god but it's just it's it's we're
gonna get to that in a minute but the
thing is the um
what's the super the projectiles the um
isn't that the what you call that's
that's the actual super what i'm
shooting the last i think that's the
melee right
yeah so that that part is is the
tracking is all over the place like
if i don't aim directly it it's it's it
feels bad when you finally get your
super
and you're missing people point blank
range like that anyway
increase the size of the warlock super
projectile proximity detonation radius
okay the proximity detonation now starts
at its
largest and scales down to 40 percent
over time so that's that circle when
you do the detonation penumbral
decreased penumbral blast
uh damage against players from 80 to 30
okay pv damage is unchanged interesting
i use more of like a slowing versus a
damaging melee i guess is the principle
now
yes that's what it seems to me it's just
more about the story and that's fair i
mean
in the day getting frozen does not feel
good you know what i'm saying and then
in some warlocks we was running
double on claw we were running claws and
getting the you know saying the double
giant going on oh god i forgot about
that yeah that'd be 160 and it's like
bang
bang bang yeah bang bang got it so ice
flare bolts
fix the bug where ice flare bolts would
continuously try
to switch targets um increase target
acquisition range of ice flails by 33
increased tuning speed of ice flare both
so they can more effectively hit nearby
type so this basically
for the warlock is when they freeze
someone they you know
they explode and then what happens is a
little tracker of stasis then looks for
the next person
to get and then pve sometimes it's
acting a little weird now this the big
one y'all we got part a little liquor
y'all [ __ ] for my chaos reach for a lot
that was so busted i'm sorry it was a
good
guy good run cass reach was never
getting used before but
man wasn't getting used recently
decrease the amount of super energy
refunded
with cancelling chaos reach early teddy
i love you my hand i hate to put your
business out there but this is for you
you was running rush out and trials
you're getting super like four times a
match
i love you he was helping me out but we
knew that was not right
as well just busted it was busted
i just like the fact that chaos reached
was actually getting some play in pvp
you know saying but yeah it was honestly
well the other piece about it was which
is also why stasis needed some
hits in the faces which is why they
needed a weight on this one is because
the range
the non-slowing like i can't tell you
how many times is a fi as a
hammer titan stasis has just screwed me
and it's not a stasis super that screws
me it's like a melee or whatever and i'm
like
i'm literally a ball of fire and you're
freezing me here what
like that's one of those yes
like i thought the light subclasses when
i
completely agree with the front of you
said that i feel like like you said if
i'm running dawn blade i get hit with
like
my natural fire ability should be an
ultimate counter
right mentally it doesn't feel like i'm
frozen while i'm i'm heating up like i
don't know
you could do damage to me sure but i was
like i feel like you shouldn't just shut
me down
when i'm a ball of fire other things
that's like debatable but
fire should be the counter to stasis
yes at least 100 it's funny you said
that because i always thought that when
i played pvp
all right so again rest in peace chaos
reach what locks it was good
let's go to the homies
yeah this big one reduce how strongly
dustfield grenade pulls players inward
effectively reducing the pull range from
9.5 meters to 6 meters
pve pull on pulse is unchanged this is
huge uh
this is huge people in pvp like you
could be next to a wall
they throw the dustfield grenade to the
side
and you get sucked bro let's get
something like fall i gotta keep getting
you know you're over there
yeah exactly so that was that need to
get changed so hopefully this
is complex that reduce the slow stacks
applied to players by the grenade
detonation from 20 to 10 stacks
dead nation's slow stacks are unchanged
against pve so this is good pve not
being touched by this
reducer slow stacks applied to players
on each tick of the grenade from 10 to 5
stacks
pre-tick slow stacks are unchanged
against pv again this is good because
it's great in pve
where you can do it on mobile enemies
adjusting the ui presentation of the
slowed status to display slow stacks
as x slash 100 instead of x 10
to increase readability when adding slow
stack amounts that are fewer than 10
ui stuff stasis crystals reduce state
crit
crystal state shatter damage against
players from wow from 85
max 55 men 55 max to 25 men
pve damage is unchanged whisper of
change which one is this whisper of
change reduced whisper of chains damage
resistance
bonus while in super from 25 to 5
damage resistance when not in super is
unchanged this only
affects damage from other guardians i
forgot what these these these fragments
are
whisper of torment fix the bug where
players could kill this one right now
yeah proc whisper of tournament while
standing inside an opponent's barricade
education a whisper of torment basically
would recharge your abilities while
standing in
a barricade so if you found like an
unused barricade of an enemy
you can sit there and take the tick
damage and never die
recharge it because you won't ever die
that's one of those things about the
barricade like it'll kill you
almost kill you but if you actually
found like an unused barricade like you
killed somebody behind it nobody's
around you just be like
stand there and then if you had to
recover done abilities are up
so like that's good
stasis fragment quest here we go
significantly reduced
objective completion values for all
crucible
fragment quests yeah he's not gambit but
the crucible stuff is still bad
crucible is worse so yeah i mean these
are the
the majority um shout out to the
community that i had a lot to say about
this
we bring it to car man like what are you
feeling now that you're seeing
stasis get all this you know attention
so to speak
um i mean it's good it's good i know uh
like true vanguard and a couple others
have like literally
put down their rifles for pvp because of
stasis
i think um i think it'll help a lot in
there because
um it was it was like every five feet
you're frozen
someone comes around the corner and just
i mean i i honestly don't see how they
still
can control you know how much frozen ice
it's still stasis
so um it'll be interesting to see what
the community thinks once that happens
but i think it's a good move in the
right direction that's for sure
um uh now i may use stasis as a hunter
you're maybe part of the problem you may
be part of the problem i
hate those people
um admittedly i'm not as good with
stasis as some of these other
crazy people but um yeah i think it's a
good thing i think it's a good uh
you know it shows they're listening
they've always shown they've listened um
a little too much sometimes but uh yeah
i think it's good dude i'm very curious
man out of this uh
mega ton of stasis info and nerfs how
are we feeling sir
well for one i love the split sandboxes
please do this more and more and more so
pve can be more powerful that's like my
big takeaway of this one is the split
sandboxes for a lot of this stuff to
make sure you don't
because that was the first thing they
did when they were nerfed the warlock
melee you're like
well i feel gimped in pve now it's like
oh i'm gonna get that guy
nope don't go anywhere so the split
sandbox is big
a lot of this stuff seems in line with a
lot of stuff i heard from like the guys
on firing range which like those five
guys are just like the epitome of like
the sandbox masters like you got the
fallouts the brewskis candy cakes
mercury's and cool guy like that's what
they do
salute uh i'm gonna pause for a second
chunk though
drop in the ten gifts thank you very
much man
appreciate the love seriously you guys
are insane tonight come on
a lot of love today trash fam cobb mob
um salute so yeah
damn uh but i think they all don't see
protect
like a lot of the things that i've seen
about stasis is the freeze sucks
just being like so like i know some
people still want to be more
slowed not frozen like the dustfield
grenade
being slower for the ticks and not quite
as like
pulling and like a lot of things seem
like a good change but not to where you
just like kill it
right yeah i don't i don't know how
they're gonna control it honestly
i mean it's still stasis yeah so it's
like if the effects like the ticks are
slower it's like it's going to take
longer for you to get frozen which is
before they would you if you watched
like a video about the dustfield grenade
you'd get sucked in unless you literally
instantly start running out you will get
frozen before you got out like this is
going to be a point to where
you'll be able to get out now you'll be
slowed the other side of it is also when
you get slowed
your accuracy is absolute trash i've
seen those videos too from some of those
guys
they're like literally looking right at
them in a grenade and they're like
and it's like they can't hit them so
there are pieces to it but again it's
like also the things where
it'd be nice to see them on the other
side go
you know hey fire's a counter for stasis
and then
and then it's the other side like when
we get whatever sub class well if we get
like the other subclasses
it'd be cool to see the counters in that
aspect if they ever go light versus dark
counters that'd be kind of fun because
then that's all different
balox when it comes to pvp overall i
think they didn't kill stasis
i think this will is a good first step
to see where all this stuff lands
over yeah i agree i think that look a
lot of this is much needed you know i'm
saying a lot of this stuff
again in the pvp space but the cool
thing about this which gave me hope for
them
from a sandbox standpoint is finally
more focused on the separation
of sandbox balance that to me is what i
got the most out of this
because again as a as a warlock you know
i remember
when they did the initial what is it
penumbral black whatever the melee's
name is
you know and they nerfed the range of it
in pvp
and it felt horrible in pve and that was
one of those things when they didn't
have that separation
you know what i'm saying like it really
affects people because one thing less we
got to be real
i'm the people at least i'm i'm i'm
pulling my cop right like
stasis is fun to me in pve like i love
stasis and pve like i
that's probably my de facto class when
i'm doing
extra hard content if i'm not running a
well as a warlock like it's if i want to
have fun and i'm
i'm freezing i'm slow i'm basically
controlling the battlefield you know
what i'm saying
and helping things out so i love it in
that respect but yeah for them to do
this i think this is a good start shout
out to that we had a funny video
they out here popping bottles right now
this stuff is getting nerfed so
you know i lost it oh he was like yeah
they feeling good and i feel for them
because look at the end of the day we
know in pvp
like cobb said getting
doesn't necessarily feel good you know
it don't feel when you when you're doing
it
it's lit but when you get got
it don't feel good i'm not breaking your
circle button like is it working is
there a delay
did i you know bro first for me because
i have
my configuration where my crouch is
outside my controller player is right
and log
in as opposed to so you can just
right so i gotta press analog it just
feels weird i know you're gonna break
off your thumbstick
and i'm gonna face it i give up i'm like
all right
damn it because it doesn't matter how
many it's not a physical button for me
and i don't want to go to the other i
forgot that other control style
the crouching is the is the button so
all or whatever
yeah i'm just like all right y'all got
me i ain't i ain't because no matter
what i do with this analog i ain't
getting out
can we get a small gofundme setup for a
cogs like replacement thumbsticks he's
going to break off right now
well what i could do i matter of fact i
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna map it
to a paddle but anyway
there you go that i don't think about
that i just i just helped my own self
out with this thank you
um at the end of the day needs to happen
good in the right direction let's see
this how this works and then let's see
how they build the other light
subclasses up because they did say they
are going to do that and that excites me
because we need a little bit more
balance with this whole situation but
yeah
good good for the most part separation
of um of pve and pvp sandbox that's that
to me is what i got out of this
so did uh did they announce any changes
in pve to weapons
because i feel like they should just
started the twab with none of this
applies to pve you know like and then
listed everything instead of
there were a few like literally if it
doesn't say it doesn't affect pvp there
are a few that are so they're
going to break them out i honestly wish
it was exactly what you said
none of this affects pve because
honestly any nerves to pve don't seem
required right now for stasis because
they buff everything
yeah stasis doesn't feel at all broken
in pvp
honest or pde it honestly doesn't feel
that powerful sometimes when you go for
kills against bosses
yeah the tornadoes are okay but like you
can combine with others now with like
the
artifact mod where it's like if they're
hit by stasis then your stuff does more
but that's like a team synergy thing
specifically but overall
by yourself especially you don't feel
like you do that much
in general you slow things down it's
more about crowd control and that is the
purpose of it which is not bad
but yeah it's like when it comes to
actual like super damage output yeah it
is
not like i'm nuking a boss with like you
know 10 hammers that i'm sitting there
throwing sunspots on it doesn't even
hold a candle though that no pun
intended there
facts yeah we did get some weapon shot
dakotas
got that nerf on console that that's
common i was like i was getting there
so is it one shot headshot only i
thought it was a one-shot body shot in
pvp
no it's headshot reduced like headshots
only
it was headshots only but it was the
amos's cone was probably the size of a
globe
like the amos is called if you looking
in their general direction it's like
like that it's going right there like
i've heard console is broken i've used
it in
pvp on pc and it still feels like i
probably shouldn't have hit that shot
and that's on like pc where i'm like i
probably was generous
and if it's worse on console yeah i was
probably pretty busted
yeah so overall
i did want to shout when is your first
dinosaur
destiny drawing going to happen yeah
it's funny you said that i actually
thought about that today
yeah i was reading the swamp because i
saw dinosaurs one and
jan said i think was the artist that had
the little dinosaur sketch
yep it got it got the wheels turned i
was like
should do some kind of which one are you
gonna do you got the raptor triceratops
or
t-rex which one's first
ah thank you for the title i like my
girlfriend always says i like the pointy
fangy
thing she likes when i do the other
stuff
just sharp stabby bitey things
but yeah so probably t-rex um when i
first saw that i got to be honest i was
a little
taken aback i know the community was
pretty excited it's something different
it's fun you know but it seemed a little
teletubbies for me when i saw
it i was like you see all these
guardians flopping around in these like
costumes but i guess it is for festival
of the loss right i mean it's just
halloween you know fun so you know
you'll be farming the infinite forest
again with a dinosaur outfit on but
it'll make for some funny looking oh
there's gonna be like jurassic park
themed videos with copyright strikes on
them like it's gonna be
yeah the videos are going to be
hilarious i bet the infinite forest will
be jurassic park theme this time
please let that happen it opens the big
door
they put like you know the ogre has a
big old skin on his head of a big like
trice
like they could have some fun with that
if they went a little over but it would
be pretty funny
um i am kind of curious when it comes to
the dino stuff
how a couple of them are going to take
shaders because theoretically
like the titan t-rex like kind of face
in the
mouth could be cool with shaders i still
think warlock's got the major short end
of the stick with tricera
yeah like love like there are
well it's like uh i can't remember i
think it was on fire team chat like
uh one of them said pterodactyl instead
for wings for a warlock it was like that
i could see
i could see that but the triceratops
just it especially the one they picked
like
triceratops got some big horns kind of
got the big head bone shield and
everything it looked like a baby
triceratops helmet for some reason
it didn't look like um because he got
like raptor and t-rex and like
looked like baby like growing up tricera
it just did not look nearly as strong
and i was like i am sorry warlocks
it was a big horn coming off their face
yeah i'm with you i wish i was that did
you want monsters or
oh i put
so i mean the last festival kind of was
monsters dracula frankenstein yeah
you're right um i was gonna say
like the next piece of that is just a
little bit of patch stuff is coming so
obviously this is the patch for
grand masters coming in this is when the
first time we're gonna be able to
see the strike the new one this season
the new strike is gonna launch
next week now it's only for season pass
holders which is first time i've ever
done that which is a little weird i
don't know where it's going to be
launchable whether it be the playlist or
the director
i don't know if it's part of like the
season
expansion or the season pass kind of
story stuff i'll be curious if it's part
of that to tell the story
but that does launch next week um
but honestly were any were either of you
guys thinking trials might not come back
this week i know it did
but before we got the news on thursday
were you guys like um
is it i just forgot about it i just
forget about it until they announce it
because it's like
from week to week like oh will it be
this week nope next week yep did you
hear this week nope
did you hear like seasonal trial season
this week
are you right you're right i mean it's
one of those things you just go week to
week you're like
i just wait for them to announce if it's
actually going to be back because you
never know there's always something
dudes out here running hacky emblems
they're like they they going crazy right
now what were they doing that broke it
last time people were just like
jumping like killing themselves letting
people go the light like how did that
even
you know like cognito if you know it you
can explain it because it's hilarious
it's i mean you probably know the
intricacies more better than me i just
know the
concept of it like they all were emblem
and then it's like
almost like a vote before basically
yeah basically it was like two people
were the hawk emblem they're like
basically the pawns in the whole thing
the two people with the other emblem
would become friends go into chat and do
like a random role on steam
and then whoever wins the random role
it's like a gentleman's agreement the
other team just jumps off the map they
do it enough and they
and they literally guarantee win because
what they would do is like okay so i win
i'm gonna switch and this is all that
allowed it was the switch of the
character was activated like a couple
weeks ago
they would switch to another character
jump back in with their real active card
the other team would jump off and die
and they get a win and then they go back
out
switch characters to the other card that
doesn't work do the same thing and if
they see a team like this match up
they're like
cool so you had like 50 of players on
almost every platform
who had flawless cards and not even five
kills
yeah okay wow so and the way you knew
who the click that was doing it they
they wore the hockey emblem
right the hockey joint
i was like it's not the first time i was
like and apparently that hopefully they
got something
and the big thing is like if you want to
switch characters like
or the rejoin feature you just can't
switch characters would be the big fix
and hopefully that's what they did
because
that would stop the whole thing if you
can rejoin an active but you can't
switch characters done
so that's all it was yeah that's
literally what it is
um but yeah it's like that pretty much
wraps up most of the twab
um big patch
decent size i mean that's like all the
stuff with stasis and preview
grandmasters that's
yeah everything coming so we'll have a
little bit of downtime
i don't know exactly how much downtime i
know they say it
usually like yeah it's the standard it's
about an hour
15 minute downtime it'll pop out up now
to everybody in the states
daylight savings time is this weekend or
saving time whatever it is called
officially
um that will change the daily reset
now as you guys can see the uh platform
will avail
they actually don't say the time change
that's the maintenance begins players
are no okay yeah that's right
players are kicked out yeah so it'll be
10 a.m pacific is when the new reset
will be
as opposed to 9 a.m so it's literally an
hour later that'll be in effect
now is that like an official from here
out it's going to be that or just this
no like daylight saving time is in
effect it's going to be like that's
right that's right yeah so it bumps it
up and then november when it goes back
into effect it drops down
but what i wanted to ask is while i
still got gene can't get out done over
here y'all are insane goodness
oh my god wow salute what i wanted to
ask both of you since we got a little
bit of time
i don't want to keep you too long but i
actually have not had a chance to talk
to cognito
because we had milan on last week for
lore and then we had an off week and
everything
a couple big topics for both of you guys
i don't want to hit everything
but from the state of the game for
destiny 2.
so i wanted to get you guys thoughts
i've given my opinion so this is
honestly for both of you so jump in when
you want to
one um this is kind of a two-piece
question
cobb you're gonna go first the delay of
witch queen
and also the fact the acknowledgement of
the light and dark 10-year saga with now
the
10th year expansion confirmed thoughts
about that whole piece of news
um the the delay of which queen uh could
be good
you know so it's kind of good when stuff
gets delayed sometimes it's not quite
ready we don't want them to rush out
anything it's not ready
on the other hand i don't want a massive
lull
like we had waiting for taken king like
that was i mean there's been a bunch
over the years
but that one was especially painful i
recall
um but as far as the state of the game
um i i think it's headed in a in a good
place especially with the
the latest announcements um of the
nerfing of stasis all that good stuff
um me personally with with that demo
i've been playing
i hadn't got a lot of time in the past
couple weeks um in destiny i got on to
grab a few pinnacles um
you know with my girlfriend and stuff
but uh other than that i haven't played
it a whole lot
um i do like the battlegrounds i think
that's really cool really fun
to go through and you just feel
overwhelmed at times you're just murking
things right and left
um but uh to what cog said
as a time sucker you know like
especially if you don't get the loot you
want at the end and
um and now that i know about the uh the
hammer thing
yeah just go for the one charge yeah but
uh i'm not
i'm not super thrilled you know right
now with it with the the new season i
think it there was some cool stuff they
brought
i really like crow's new look but
i'm still i'm still waiting for that um
i love the new hidden missions let me
say that i love those
those are my favorite to run hands down
but uh yeah i'm just waiting for that
super juicy
dlc like it it seems to
i don't know maybe they're not doing
that anymore i don't know
i guess which queen's gonna be a massive
one right they announced but yeah that's
theoretically gonna
be the big one because i mean they said
that they described the stuff that they
want to do
is they really want to take this one and
they they're like
they want to make it you know a
definitive action mmorpg they've said
that but they also want to go
into the point where it's uh here's the
line uh they want to do it unlike
anything we've ever attempted before
with characters arcs heroes and villains
that persist over multiple future
releases like
the storytelling they're doing now it
sounds like this is like to the next
level
for the general like lore story
everything going on in the game
that bethune's got to be big so it seems
like they want it to be
[ __ ] what about you man i i haven't
honestly had a chance to talk to you
about this so we can't not
so more so about the light and dark and
then like the witch fingerling well
first do you care about the delay um and
then also like
the light dark saga we now have an
expansion past
lightfall and the fact that there's also
this is the saga of 10 years
yeah fact that what the hell's after
that yeah no absolutely no i mean the
delay
you know obviously you know you don't
you don't necessarily excited when you
hear about delay but
it's one of those things where you know
again like i've said where it's like you
know what you know it's
always better to delay a product so that
you get the best
possible product right you we want them
to be at their best
and it kind of makes sense i mean
obviously let's be real you know um
beyond light got delayed you know what i
mean like so we always wonder like how
does this affect them because we're so
used to the old activision schedule
every september it's gonna be this you
know what i'm saying so now they're
they're independent they're an indie
studio
it was like speaking of activision
that's something they kind of wanted to
do
but never got to so yeah so like that's
cool
look how uh the delay helped cyberpunk i
mean
yeah yo you stupid
wow
see that's why you need x-box
i'm just joking i'm just joking
anyway look at the end of the day delay
is good you know
um the thing i got out of it with the
light and dark thing
is it it there's a part of me that's
confused because all we've known in
destiny is light versus dark for all
these years
so it's like what the hell are they
going to talk about afterwards but then
there's a part that excites me because i
know
that luke and mark have now have got
elevated
to this like grand masters of the lore
position
right so as far as the future of destiny
moving forward so to me
that's big picture stuff you're talking
about movies you're talking about
putting destiny in all these different
mediums
so that means you've got to have a plan
post light versus dark so i'm very
curious i mean it's it's exciting i i
don't know what the hell that is you
know again
all we've known is this all the light
versus the traveler versus the
space doritos you know that's what we've
known
you know so what's gonna happen um
you know in the past we've heard yo
you're not ready
yo it's gonna be bold you know what i
would i had the tweet yesterday that
seemed to push that even more when you
said people
bungee like half the bunch of employees
literally tweeted
bungie like whatever happened yesterday
what happened today
they hyped super pumped so again i don't
know
if that's just the hype of them as a
studio
if that's the hype because we see i
think it was barrett changed his
his his twitter to director of
unannounced
game right you know there's another
thing
and that could be the matter could be
moving further along
we don't know something's going on with
the entire
destiny you know as a company as a
studio
they're galvanized right they're excited
they're like they're super pumped that's
the energy we getting from them
so i'm very curious to see what that
that that translates to
because um you know as far as destiny we
just i'm happy that the game is
profitable i'm happy that they're able
to do
a bunch more stuff that we learned right
now it just comes down to
where does that go past light dark where
does matter fall into this and the last
thing i'll say
is um this is for me this is this is
comic book cog now
i would like i want like if they go in
light versus dark
i want a moment avengers in-game kind of
moment
yeah we're gonna lose people and
it's going to be either like zavala
sacrifices himself to save all the
guardians or
like i want loss i want
something like this the stakes are high
and in order for this or whether it be a
race
you know we know cabal is going to
linger something has to happen so this
thing can hit
hard because you know the same way i
felt forsaken hit hard
we found out yo we rotted for kate yo
who where them barons at you know
it gives you that emotional connection
and we haven't had that in a while
so that's you know not that you just got
to sell def
to sell the game but i think it would be
epic on an avengers style even listen
you know i'm osiris fanboy but even if
owen you know saying like
some loss that like you like yo
the doctors ain't playing like it's it's
real out here like you're saying like
yo or civ or we could do comic bacon
we could do destiny civil war everybody
taking these verses
like yo fam we're not with the light no
more you know what i'm saying we over
here i thought they were going to start
alluding to that with eris
drifter you know i thought it was going
to be like yo we taking sides and this
is the way to do it
and then we have that kind of thing so
i'm excited i'm hoping
that luke's elevation and mark's
elevation to the grand masters of the
law
put them in that direction and then
we'll see what nice
uh topic two yes sunsetting being sunset
thoughts uh cobb instead of cog
cobb that's not confusing yeah not
confusing at all
um as far as sunsets i like
holding hands and walking on the beach
under the stars
into the moonlight into the moonless
night so he can explain
how constellation exactly
plus
[Laughter]
um yeah i think it's good i think
sunsetting stinks
i think uh i don't know
like i do like out with the old m with
the new
like if they were gonna sunset they
should replace it with new gear or
and new weapons and like it goes back to
the the
taco bell thing i always call it where
you take the same ingredients and you
whip them up and you
serve it back to the people like oh
something new
i feel like that's kind of what happens
you know they get us excited for old
weapons we're excited for the old vault
of glass
why isn't it the vault of plastic and
they've you know it's a whole
another you know like but i get it you
know games
games are hard but sun setting i'm i'm
fine with sunsetting the sun setting
yeah um yeah we i was out
um when all this went down for my
surgery but um
yeah i've got conflicting things about
this
oh gotta know gotta know yeah um here's
the thing
as you know um as cobb wouldn't know me
and e went
at each other very hard at the judicial
announcement of this thing
right and at the time i was just like yo
you know i don't understand and the
arguments presented to me not by e but
by
bungie right was yo
power creep you know
we getting to the point where it's too
hard and difficult we have to make
things better than this
and you know as a result this is why now
even though i didn't agree
at the time i understood the argument
the thing
i put my line into saying was damn it
don't you dare touch my exotics or
it's gonna be a problem right that was
probably where i ended up and i ended
up coming around right to the idea of it
so as we go on and now
you know what the first introduction of
it what i'm going to say was it beyond
life
light it literally lasted to a season
right so we all like
you know all this stuff that we've had
all the you know season of
the dawn a lot of these weapons that we
loved you know breakneck all these
pinnacle stuff
you know starts to go right now part of
me
i said you know what i understand
because look when you got something like
a breakneck or recluse mountain top
these things probably intrinsically are
so powerful it's hard for them to
balance
so they're going to get rid of it
starting to get into the acceptance
phase
however the problem i had like he had
with me was that we both were like yo
if you're going to remove all this where
is the infusion replacement
and we didn't get that we got a little
bit we got a couple of
you know red and blue crayon beyond
light weapons
okay cool you know we didn't get this
for everything that
it was so bad if you remember
when they would give us bounties to do
kills with a certain
like machine gun we're like yo i don't
even got a machine gun that does this or
like how many exists there now because
you don't took all this
all the way so the issue became the
implementation like
they date the idea i understood even
though i didn't necessarily agree
but it came down to you didn't fulfill
your promise by infusing the game with
the the weapons
new weapons that you took so now we get
to this
i hear the announcement i'm gonna be
honest with you yeah i was like
i kind of rolled my eyes with it not
that cause my thing is just like
why the hell did we do this to begin
with you know what i'm saying because
it's like
you know to get rid of mountain top and
close that's literally i swear the two
they could have gotten rid of
oh so and my thing is now okay look
am i happy it's going probably yes
because now i get to keep stuff
and you know whatever but does this
solve the power creep problem
does this solve this goal that they
talked they told us
that yo this is you know it's going to
be harder things we just got to make
things better
how are we going to solve it and now
let's be real the warm itself stuff that
stay in now
and raise earth but yeah yeah so they
talked all they hinted
was that they are going to allude to
other methods or something
like there's still going to be some
revisiting of some way of balance
and to me sound like
i again maybe i'm bugging if it's not
like sunset still being returned at
another point
i don't necessarily feel we're in the
clear and it's com i think we're clear
now yeah but in the future the the same
problem they complained about is still
gonna exist
how are they gonna balance stuff if all
this stuff is staying around
come which cream right and if that's the
issue so to me that
i felt i don't know if it was a public i
don't feel as a physical combination of
a public pressure thing
and probably a resource thing
and they're just like yo we just can't
do it right now
it was surprising to me i'll just say
this it was very surprising to me that
they reneged
so hard on it i didn't so
fast it's so fast like that was the
thing so or maybe it just maybe just
comes down to look
they couldn't deliver on the promise
realistically of any infusion of the new
weapons of making all these new weapons
you know what i'm saying and they say
hey let's just put it on timeout for now
until we get there
but outcry of the community too yes yes
definite combination
but it's like but yeah if you're like
hey what's one of the issues that people
are gonna have don't give me the same
weapons that you're gonna reissue over
and over
right literally when we read one of the
things about like the new dungeons
reissuing and i just like lost my mind
and i was just like yeah it's like old
armor old weapons just a few new perks
on there i'm like i don't
want to go get another what you said he
that's said mexican food like no
judgment against like
mexican food or anything like that it is
tortilla with cheese meat or vegetable
just in a different shape fashion or
form that's literally
what that is there's a comedian who
jokes about that one so
i got you know it's like for me too it
was like
i'm with you for me i was like and
somebody in chat said it too it's like i
just want to know
good question whenever you get your go
figure back i'm like i'm gonna be pissed
yeah i'm gonna be mad as hell
now granted they couldn't go back and
say if you held on to weapons from
all time then you were able to pull them
back out of the vault and they won't be
sunset they couldn't do that
because they officially had said hey
this stuff isn't going forward so
from this point literally if it hadn't
been sunset yet then it's still
active granted some people literally in
my chat the same day i read this thing
out were like
i just deleted my season stuff and it's
just like
yep so it's and that was the big
question between travis and paul and the
people i've talked to about this was
just like
how do you plan to do something where
you wipe out 70
of our like arsenal and not
have a plan yeah to have a decent chunk
of stuff come back in there and it's
like
either they thought it was enough they
thought they could come up with it fast
enough and it just didn't pan out
but it was just weird to see i think
it's that i think your answer is i i
that's the only thing that makes sense
to me i thought they could
they thought they could and then in
their defense as much as we're ragging
on them right now
with covet and everything that's going
on maybe from a resource they're like yo
we cannot
pump these out as fast as we thought
we're gonna have to pull the thing on it
and that's what it is because
it was a very strong like it's very
strange reneging
of something that they they they put a
layout in the sand they were
all in sunset came out they was like yo
this is how it's going to be
you know what i mean so i agree with
it's got to be it's got to be that
because i can't think of anything else
to to just fall back on it so
so quickly pretty much they had a huge
piece about pvp we're already seeing
some of the first one of that
now granted they didn't say anything
about maps so again they've got to prove
the pvp stuff people have been saying
that
yeah i think we've called it forever
vault of glass is coming in season 14.
there's gonna be this weird world first
triumph challenge
race thing yes um
i know we've kind of talked about that a
little bit i guess we'll just kind of
have to see how that pans out
i will have to say at some point i think
cog and i are gonna have to play vault
together
yes we do we do have to we don't play
much together that much in the first
place but we are definitely gonna have
to find some time to play vault together
because
it's if king saul comes back he's got to
play with me if vault comes back i got
to play with him
we will have to do that i hope king's
fall comes back man
gosh i hope you know it's common yeah i
do retro raids with that every year
my prediction i said it here for right
around
probably the season after
or before witchcree you're gonna it's
gonna be so
it would be like the it would be the
spring season like
14 so it'll be 18 is where if you're
gonna have a taken king that's where you
put it
yeah which would you yeah uh transmog
around the which queen yeah like you
said
yep yeah cause it builds hype up right
there yeah
next to each other thematically you got
transmog coming honestly one of my big
fist pump moments while reading this
thing is shaders will no longer be
consumable
jesus thankful thank you whoever who you
pray to
thank you like that's like the shade all
button
that's gonna be in there that's gonna be
yours it's gonna be
it's gonna be in there yep the shade all
is gonna be in there as well so
shaders no longer consumable shade
everything's gonna be in there so that's
huge
um
one one word answer are you worried
about the price cost of
synth of armor synthesis tokens
yeah that's the transmog currency no
and here's why they said from the get-go
they're going to give you a bunch
like 10 of them they'll probably give
you like i would say it was like
probably 10 for two sets of arm it would
be my guess not going to worry for the
first couple armor pieces
after that i probably cog
yeah i mean i don't know i mean i gotta
see it's what i'm doing a bunch you
gotta wait and see until you actually
get it
one would hope that yo hook us up
because we want to we want to look flat
out here guardian i want my i want my
warlock drip i want you know i might
want to do
everything it's clean on me first sub
class i'm waiting but this is long
overdue
i'm excited it sees it in that respect
because i those quality that we've
changed
final one um
just so we don't go too long the power
cap going from
50 to 10 literally they did this in
season of dawn
i wanted both your thoughts on this one
because we have been down this path
before
do you like it don't like it thoughts
okay um
[Music]
i guess not these days it doesn't bother
me as much because
i'm not as power hungry i guess you
could say we're like every season i'm
like i've got to max
to the max top it's like i haven't even
hit 1300 yet
i think i don't even think i've hit uh i
don't know i'm like 30 like below that
but
i don't know it's busy man yeah i guess
these days it
it doesn't bother me as much if i was
trying to you know gain that power
this and that the only thing that
bothers me is quit taking away my extra
free light from my uh
come on man like you start the new
season it's like wait i was
oh yeah yeah yeah every single time
every season
yeah yeah i mean
you know meant mentally i'm so
accustomed to it you know this whole
power ground power chase but yeah i've
calmed down on trying to you know be
like old i got to be so
crazy cause you know what it is too it's
like it's a lot of times doesn't even
matter because a lot of the harder
activity scales
so it's just like what's the purpose i'm
not even feeling strong for being at
1360
for what you know yeah i'm not
really that substantially you know more
powerful or have more you're still
getting one shot by that annoying sniper
in the corner
so my you know me being a higher number
than my man in the fire team it ain't
necessarily you know i mean that big of
a difference so
yeah the shrink to me it always comes
down to the activities and what you're
doing
and the chase for the loot as the
excitement
so if they want to go to this route for
seasons
i'm fine you know i mean now for the for
like when you're doing the expansion
that'll probably still be big right when
it's a when there's a raid or there's
something there's a number to aspire to
to qualify
for from really cool in-game activity
slash
slash raid i don't have a problem with
that in that respect
but the the seasonal stuff like then
there's really outside of this
grand fall night for you know how i feel
about grand master nightfall
already um you know there's no incentive
to say yo
in my clan i'm 13. you know saying like
this
right you don't you don't mean nothing
family we're still kind of
in the same pocket so you know for me
that's where i'm at it's just like
um it's just a number an arbitrary
number right now that they used to and
i'm actually okay
with them making it a 10 point thing you
know per
season if that's the new thing and then
for the expansion
you you know you go all out with your 50
100 whatever the new number is or
whatever
that's where i'm at you know i'm saying
what about you for me honestly i was
like i've talked about this a couple
times but for me i'm at the point to
where
until it's just this i'm like the
artifact losing that
doesn't feel great then it's like hey i
could have done grand masters but you
got to grind it out again
like i'm kind of at the point that
theoretically it's like
and it's this weird thing and i've said
i don't know how to fix it because they
pretty much have to do a full rework on
the leveling system to me for it to
matter
properly but like i would rather see
seasons add content
and not require the level like as you
said the artifact
kind of sucks too because you're like oh
how much time have you literally the way
you get to
right now you can get plus 10. how do
you get to
grandmaster nightfalls it's nothing
about skill it is
like okay there's skill to do them but
it's literally time
how many counties have you done how many
of this have you done the seasonal
challenges
have not completely fixed the bounties
the bounties are still a substantial
piece of your grind
so then it's like okay and those i've
seen people like go to solo presage
and i'm like i'm not high enough yet to
go into there at a high enough level
where i can do it fast enough and it's
literally like
how much time do i want to put into
leveling this one number up for this one
or two activities
when i can do literally everything else
and here's the point two doors i
just stole my thought what i was about
to say again if you want
us as players to invest right and
and do and be committed to the power
grind then damn it you better have some
crazy stuff in grand master right you
better have some
to make me go you i gotta get my level
up the only time i thought they did it
semi-okay
i will admit was the introduction of the
what is it the legendary law sector so
i'm like okay i got
a little bit because now you know if i
want this exotic you know what i'm
saying
i got to get my behind in there solo and
do x y and z you know what i'm saying
but if there's no chase there's no
powerful instead of no exclusive exotic
there's nothing
that people are not going crazy to do
that and they and again it
always comes down to rewards in-game
rewards
reward correctly people will want to get
in there
just message your last you jumped in
remember what is it last month whatever
it was two months
two weeks three weeks ago when messenger
was in trials right with desperado
whatever
i saw you in there right yeah i had help
but yeah i did i get
i got dragged in and i was like all
right we'll give it a shot but yeah it's
like it is one of those like desperados
one of those rare pinnacle perks like
there's nothing like that in a grand
master and on the pve side it's still
pretty minimal but that's kind of thing
it's like we did season of dawn
people were like hey the 10 doesn't feel
great then we went up to 50.
and now we're going back to something we
already said not people didn't like so
i'm like
it's it's still a band-aid over a bullet
hole because
yeah it's the issue of why am i leveling
like if you want to add a seasonal
content and tell a story and stuff like
that make that stuff compelling
add cool guns to go after but it's like
oh you could like
yesterday you could do grand you could
do a nightfall today you can't just
because it's a new season
nothing else changed besides you have to
grind this crap out again
that that has to change for me in the
long run because as you said cobb of
like
i have not gone nearly as hard in
multiple seasons
i'm just about to hit 100 rank for the
season which is
i don't know if i honestly hit 100 last
season but it's just like it's been
slower because to me it's like there are
a couple things that i haven't been able
to do and it's like i would love to work
on a solo master
presage but also on the other side do i
want to beat my head against grinding up
to like
two like level 200 in the season pass to
be like pinnacle
1305 plus a 20 power level so i've got a
little bit of a
of a delta over it just to do that one
thing
and for me it's like the guide would be
cool but it's like that just i would
there's so many other things again for
my sanity i would much rather not spend
that time
and if i do get to that point when you
take it away in a new season that's
i'm just like ah and that's where it's
been
like hard for me and i'm seeing this 10
and i'm like now it's literally just the
slow pinnacle and you're just going to
bump them a little farther away every
time and the artifacts are going to
reset
yeah it's just so i was like i'm hoping
this is maybe
10 for the next two months and then
something
bigger changes for which queen like
there's gonna there's got to be some
substantial change in the leveling
because
i'm not the only there's a lot of people
that just they're not a fan of it
anymore it's just it's just an
arbitrary number to say you can or can't
do this if you put this much time in
and that's it yeah that did bug me
because i
i went hard on the lost sectors uh last
season like for all the you know the
chest and arms and then you know i found
out the new gear for this season like
sweet day one i went to like
try to go like what the first day you
just get well
kick back down the hill oh you climb up
the hill and then
kick back down it'd be cool if they um i
don't know maybe it's like somehow
implemented
you know half the power you earn in your
artifact you can carry over you know or
something some kind of benefit
like not just fill this thing up and
then take it away
and then all the cool perks in there
that don't matter if you select it
you got to go into your gun and throw
you know throw those pieces on like
so why even is that like i don't know
i don't know like and it's it's a it's a
pain point for me that i hope they
address in a witch queen because if it
continues for another
six seasons it's hard to like
oh to go for the top level stuff which
is fun to do
but i was like it doesn't feel it's just
a time thing that bungie wants you to
spend time in the game
but if it's just arbitrary for time it's
not the right reason
so i always have this like every season
i always have this
this odd feeling after day one or day
two like
you do all the cool new stuff you eat up
the little missions and then there's
this moment where i'm like
yeah what are you doing what am i
supposed to work on now like
okay i'll go to europa and do you know
but i don't know i missed the days of
everything that came out we had a little
mini story of missions you know like
dlcs basically but
i know that takes time and yeah but i
want you brother
i'm with you man well said
that is all i got for this week
obviously wanted to finally touch on
that stuff
thank you for the extra time cobb
appreciate it um
but as we wrap this episode up i wanted
to say thank you for joining us for one
amazing artist cool to hear about the
astrology
and astronomy i did it too damn it
yeah those two are too close and you've
probably heard the word astrology more
in your life just because people
apparently love cancer and
sagittarius and all that crazy stuff
like we're talking about the actual
science stars that's the good stuff
but that being said like just like for
anybody who hears this
um and everything where can they find
you is there anything
you're working on any like planned
pieces in your head just
the floor is yours for anybody who hears
this where to find you what you got
coming
um i'm cobb one art everywhere uh all my
socials
um youtube i have a channel with time
lapse art videos i have a red bubble
store
i have i stream on twitch few and far
between these days but i still do um
so yeah uh as far as pieces um
i have 33 star wars cards that i have to
draw this weekend and my goal is to have
them inked
by the end of next week so that's
on my plate uh as i mentioned before i
might do a title piece is that her name
nice yep
um old tusk face but uh
yeah uh i appreciate you guys having me
on it's been a lot of fun
anytime man anytime love come hang out
with you guys you already know
absolutely well believe me it was the
pleasure was absolutely ours and you're
welcome back
chad from you guys on airplanes to right
here
because yeah we went florida i think you
came through dallas and kept going home
for you
so that was funny because it was you and
gamma both
like headed back the same way gamma went
to fort worth you went a little farther
so like
yeah it's like the art that artist row
between i
spent some money on artistro but it was
like you and monkiss and gamma
and just the talent in the community
like honestly i can tell you by the time
it comes to gcx next year because i
assume you're gonna do a digital event
this year
next year holy crap we have like there's
so
many amazing people between doing this
podcast for multiple years now
i'm we're never going to have enough
time to just say hello to everybody so
it's cool it's going to be awesome but
it's i love spending like a couple hours
with you guys that's why we appreciate
the extra time that you give because
it's really cool to get to know you more
and now when you're like hey you want to
grab a drink later it's like
sure like it feels awesome do you want
to get a drink
i'm in albuquerque though so okay later
is gonna be like sunday if i'm driving
it's gonna take me a minute to get there
so
um but yeah i was like so uh cog
i know you've had a couple of rough
weeks and everything but uh
what do you got coming up i know you had
shout out by the way to ilp last weekend
they had jason ronald on the man
of the xbox like quite literally if you
guys have not watched that episode it's
an
awesome awesome episode go check it out
that's like
that's a deep dive you want to listen to
so definitely go check that one out of
course quality content from the
gentleman over there
cracking me up every time between all
the you guys so check them out
uh but what do you got coming up man
yeah man first of all salute to um
[ __ ] for pulling up and this is
really cool getting a chance to build
with you
always good to speak to people from my
era
old folk don't get a chance to reminisce
about back we were the last generation
that played till dark outside
man for real i love i love what you're
doing love the art
love what you represent the astronomy
thing was dope and um like i said i love
anybody i could talk hip-hop graffiti
way we good
i appreciate it man i appreciate it
appreciate you guys the whole community
everyone out there
i love everyone artist communities dope
we love to celebrate them
yeah for me man you already know cognito
on twitter all that good stuff
again appreciate all the support you
know what everything i was going through
prior to past two weeks to surgery
you know losing two friends and stuff
like that but the community has been
amazing everybody's been hitting me up
reaching out
and again thank you e for the shout out
for the jason ronald that was a big
thing i prepared a lot for that
and i mean i felt it came out pretty
good it seems like i got a lot of
positive feedback for that so salute
this week um on iop every sunday's
launch day at 1pm eastern ireland's
podcast youtube check us out
we got my man acg he's going to pull up
man the king the lord of reviewers you
know what i mean so
he's real cool hell yeah i listen to him
yeah
man i've listened to so many of his his
i love his like
yeah yeah this is another one guys don't
miss this one because
yeah his reviews sorry to steal you but
like i've watched
a fair chunk of his reviews like there
are certain people for review styles
like
skill up acg there's certain people's
review styles for like that time space
that some people go like really really
deep but that like
30 minute like he's like 20 to 30
usually solid skillup might be a little
longer but both of those guys
huge respect that's awesome man that's
angry censorship
dude have been building been trying to
work together for a while
finally the dates of the stars online so
this sunday
he's gonna pull up we're gonna do a deep
dive talk that that og gaming talk and
uh what's going on in the industry but
again
appreciate the support and of course
every friday
generally we do that last for a podcast
you know what i'm saying man eating
ninja in the cheat at the campfire
talking that dusty talk and we're
sneaking a lot of outriders i've noticed
it but it's good
more luda shooters are good man
competition is good yeah that's
that's kind of the thing i hope without
writers is it's not the destiny killer
it's not going to be it's not a live
service game i just hope honestly hitler
yeah i like it i like the destiny filler
it's okay to play
i just finished immortals phoenix rising
this week i had a ton of fun i
was like it's a kind of a fun open world
greek dry
cheeky humor game by the time i got done
i was like oh the boss battle was kind
of a let down
no no there was a big phase too it had a
nice little finish
it was kind of cool so uh i mean as for
me honestly cobb thank you very much for
joining us later
i want to say a couple more things if i
could just real quick absolutely man
first thing i'd like to give a shout out
to the cobb mob fam bam
you're going out there hanging out there
you go and secondly um if you're an
artist out there
and you do art come hop in our discord
we share a lot of art in there
and if you post some art on twitter tag
me in it i will retweet your art
anyone that tags me with their art i
will retweet it because i love sharing
art so
i just want to get that out there i
forgot to say that oh absolutely like at
any time there's twitter if there's
something i think
i always try and like reply and say this
is amazing if there's an osiris piece
cog knows i tagged him in literally
every single one of them
yeah you got to they got it if you see
osiris they gotta tag him that's
anything
serious or syrian trials any of that or
just warlock business anything warlock
business
try he tag i'm like oh what's that
what's going on then i immediately
follow the artist really i'm like oh
yeah
all the time man for sure uh
for me uh at some point i'm gonna be
starting orion the blind forest
so that was the recent vote so it was
between hellblade and ori
because last time the vote was for me it
was between
what we played immortals and then hell
blade and ori
and it was a like tight fight the whole
way and i think immortals pulled it out
in the last second this time
is literally like like 66 33
ori beat hellblade now blade is going to
come
after both of these are about eight to
nine hours hellblade is next but
you guys will you guys will see me
playing ori kind of on like you know the
off variety that the
day that i'll have still covering
destiny outriders i'm probably gonna
start doing character
class deep dives just so you guys get a
little preview of how each one feels
before you jump in just so you can get
into
which one you may like and not because
the biggest thing i can tell anybody
about outriders lately
if you try one character and it doesn't
quite hit like you need to try the other
side
because you've got the pyromancer and
techno
yeah the pyromancer and techno are like
more ranged
and then devastator and trickster are
more close now you can like
play with both and there's some styles
to both but those have that kind of feel
so if you don't love one try the other
vice versa more more cover less cover
crazy in your face
but that's been kind of the tree it's
like hundreds of that's exactly what i
want to go that's
crazy deep yeah that's going to be part
of those is like literally like
forest it's good
that's another thing is like i would
love to see destiny go deeper into skill
trees like that it doesn't have to be
crazy but like
between the armor mods and the skill
trees like
you're gonna be able to take a class and
feel completely different than somebody
else which is gonna be fun
uh so outriders destiny ori's next and
the hell blades after
those are like one to two max probably
streams so i'm trying to knock those out
because then come april 1st it's
outrider's destiny just like neck and
neck the whole way so
that's what i got did you or are you
going to play hellblade
in your headphones i play everything in
headphones
because
that's that's literally the one thing
i've heard about hell played is like
audio is crucial so have you not played
it no no
have not i can't wait what it is
designed to make you
feel what it's like to like mental
health
it is it's crazy dude just wait just
wait and create the volume in your
headphones yeah
it's the 3d audio is spectacular that'll
be one where like the game volume is
probably about the same as my voice or a
little less so like the
chat can see it too so that'll be big so
those are what's coming for me um twitch
twitter youtube it's a bonus everywhere
you guys know to find me
the love has been amazing lately um
everywhere so thank you guys for that
uh if you guys made it this far in i
probably need to do this in the
beginning
go listen to this on audio on youtube on
ilp
on my youtube channel but also like
spotify itunes wherever you listen to
audio podcasts taking with you in your
pocket walking your dog whatever you do
we're there too and thank you guys for
the growth there been awesome
um that was the longest outro i've ever
had sorry about that
um but again we are also gonna go raid
ill physics
tony out there crushing it in pvp uh
amazing gentleman right there just got
the shout out recently by bunji
so go hang out with him see if we can
get him on here at some point definitely
an awesome guest that is a smart pvp man
for sure
so i'd love to like pick his brain and
okay we'll be excited for a crucible
episode as usual
but as we wrap this one cobb thank you
very much cog of course
and then for this episode number 140 hit
another round
number so march 12th episode number 140
thank you guys very much and it has been
the last word
all right guys we're gonna go raid ill
physics you guys have fun
i will send you guys over there please
spread some love to ill physics awesome
guy thank you guys very much
uh chat y'all have been fantastic go
spread the love to another channel now
see ya
all right keep that recording i
completely forgot oh you're totally fine
man it's all good
we can just do our outro claps
get the ninja i'll choke clap i'll just
work with that yeah
pop
if i don't do it you don't hear it oh
well it did it faded down i heard it
yeah clap
clap clap and then there you go weird no
flap clap clap